And you can see an example up
here
on the slide  of kind of what
this looks like with a sample
that we  built for a recipe
recommendation
app.  And essentially,  what
you
provide is you give the tool a
list of phrases  or sentences
that you expect the user to
say.
And you  can see that API.AI is
automatically highlighting
individual
entities out of those elements
that are  actually interesting
to your application.  So for
this
case, it's a recipe
recommendation,
so we're looking for  things
like
a protein, a temperature, a
type
of dish,  and all of these
things
are just recognized
automatically
by API.AI.  Now, the other
really
nice  thing about this tool is
you don't have to pick every
single
element that you think the
user
might say.   Because of the
machine
learning element to this
system,
you simply have to provide a
number of samples up front
and
then the system can
interpolate
and interpret what a  user
might
say so that you only have to
give
it some  additional data and
then
API.AI will always do the
right
thing picking out all of it.
And then your back-end
applications
has to simply respond to that
structured  data.  So you no
longer
have to try to interpret out
of
the string the information
that
you need.
We've also announced the Google
Assistant SCK,  which allows
you
to because he had the Google
Assistant
directly into your custom
hardware
projects.  We provide  out of
the box support for Linux and
Android things.   But the API
is based on GRPZ, so you could
pretty much  import it to
anything.
You can either use a button
trigger
to trigger the assistant, or
you
can use a  library for support
.
You can trigger it just like we
do  with consumer devices.
All
you have to do is provide a
microphone
and a speaker, and then you
can
use the  actions on Google to
implement additional
functionality,
such as device control.
.  Device
makers can easily  integrate
devices
with our home graph.  Home
graph
knows  the state of all
connected
devices so that when you ask
it
to dim the lights just a
little
bit, it knows how to  do that
in an intelligent way.  The
user
makes
acquires  and then smart home
controls those devices.  As a
device  maker, you don't have to
worry about handleing with all
of that speech input, just with
requests with very  specific
values.  The user speaks what it
wants and  smart home
coordinates across all their
devices across  the home.  Even
across different device makers.
Firebase also has an amazing
suite of applications  and
services that are useful for IOT
.  Realtime database database,
for example, makes it easy to
synchronize the  state of
various devices across a mobile
app and between  various IOT
devices in your application.
Authentication  is another
example that enablers us to
associate devices  with the user
's account.  And with, boy,
things, all of  these are easier
with IOT because it can use the
same  existing libraries and
SDKs right on this devices.
We also announced core back at I
O.  This is a  fully-managed
service on Google Cloud platform
that  allows you to connect
millions of devices directly
over  Google cloud.  Whether you
want to connect millions of
devices and scale them
automatically, you have no need
to worry about provisioning the
infrastructure or adding
visual.  It has native support
for standard protocols,  and you
can access all of your
data globally disbursed  as one
system.  It's great for maps
scale type of  provisioning.
This is converse with the
Firebase user  case which works
for individual user type cases.
You  can use cloud services
that are part of the cloud
platform, so BigQuery to analyze
your massive scale data  and
visualize that for internal use
as well.
So that's sort of a whirlwind
tour of all the  different
services that we have available
for IOT and  the Google
Assistant.  I want you to be
sure to play  with all of the
demos that we have in the IOT
sandbox  and the assistant
sandbox, and our team will be on
hand  to answer questions as
well.
Immediately following this
session, I'm headed  over to the
IOT office hours for anyone who
has  additional questions about
any of these platforms can  ask
me directly.  Later on today,
we also have hands-on  training
for Android Things where you can
get your hands  on some of
these devices and build them and
play with  the application.
And we also have another one on
Google  actions tomorrow.
One more thing.  We want you to
get started on the  right path
by building cool devices for IOT
.  So  everyone who has attended
this session today is going to
go home with one of our
developer kits for Android
things.
[Applause]
Make sure you grab a card on
your way out, and you  can pick
up the kit downstairs.  So thank
you so much  for your time
today, and I hope you enjoy the
rest of  the conference.
[Applause]
>> Hello, everybody,.
If you think you're going to get
me to say nothing nothing, I'm
going to say it.  Welcome to
Poland,  obviously, and welcome
to this session on Kotlin.  I'm
sure a majority of you here
have heard of Kotlin.  Have
seen a little bit of it.  Just
keep it to yourself.  And  we'll
start to -- I'll show you a
bunch of different  things with
Kotlin, and I will do it a
little bit  differently this
time.  I'll compare it a little
bit to  some other programming
language, and we will pick Java
today to kind of give you a
feel of where and what we  try
and provide you with value.
Okay?  And just to get  started,
this is my main function, so
you can see it up  there.  And I
can write "Hello"," and I can
run this, and  that's as simple
as it gets.
So to start with, you don't have
a public static  void main and
class, you just have basically
top-level  functions.  It's
JavaScript, but in a good way.
And you  can basically define
your function as you like.  So I
can say function, for instance
, print message, and then  have
a parameter here of string, and
then print line,  and then the
message.  Okay?  And I can do
string here  and do whatever I
want.
Now, notice that there's no
return type.  By  default, it's
unit, and you can omit it if you
don't  have a return type.  And
functions, again, concise, what
we try to do is make functions
as simple as possible and  as
easy as possible to write and as
concise as possible  to write
and a expression returns a value
, you can just  write that as
what we call a single function
expression.   So I can write
that as X plus Y; right?  I
don't need to  put the return
type, I don't need to open the
curly  braces or close the curly
braces, just write it as
simple as that.  And of course
you can call these  functions
whatever you want.  Message or
something.   Okay?
Now, how does this help in terms
of, like, what  you already
have.  Okay?  The syntax is a
little bit  more concise, and I
write fun instead of not fun,
and I  write unit instead of
void, but what does that give me
?   Let's take a look at, for
example, overloaded functions
in Java; right?  This is over
loaded methods in Java, and  I'm
going to -- now take a look at
overloaded.  So you  can see
that this is already somewhere
where it's  cutting down code.
I don't need to do this over
loaded  method anymore in Java.
Obviously, this -- I'm putting
this outside in its own, like,
top-level function.  But  this
could actually be a function of
a class.  So don't  worry about
the class.  The class is here.
There you go go.  Now you've got
the class.  There.  Now you've
got  the class.  Happy?  There.
People say, oh, there's no
classes in Kotlin.  Yes, there
are.
So what am I doing?  Essentially
, I'm just passing  in optional
parameters; right?  Simple as
that.  Why do  I have to have
all of this with all of this
code over  and over again if
essentially I'm doing the same
thing  but with a different
number of parameters?  And then
of  course I can call this, and
I can say, for example,
a  Val here.  By the way, it
means immutable only.  If you
want to reassign something,
declare it a bar.  My rule  of
thumb is don't do it.  Just
declare it a Val.  And  then I
can do it here and then print
message.  Okay?  So  I can pass
in one parameter, I can pass in
two  parameters, I can pass in
three parameters.  And the  good
thing is that you can see the
intelligent name of  the
parameter, but we actually have
named parameter in  Kotlin too.
So if I want to pass in the
suffix first, I  can put in
suffix and then here I would say
the prefix  and pass in the pre
fix, and then this would become
the  actual message; right?  I
could alternate the order in
which
I want to pass the parameter.
And this is useful  of course
not only for order, which why
would you want  to do it anyway?
But it's useful when you have
multiple  function that has 200
parameters and playing a game;
right?  So you can start to im
mute those things.  But  why
bother?  You could hack things
together; right?
Now, Kotlin does have classes,
as I have shown you you, I've
created a class.  And one of the
quintessential examples we
show, let's say custom Java,
and show custom Kotlin.  There
you go.
Now -- and, again, you're going
to say big deal.   Any ID
generates this for me.  Yes, it
does but the ID  doesn't
maintain it for you.  And the ID
doesn't say  look at that
because that's just boilerplate
what I've  generated for you;
right?  I don't know if someone
's  modified all of that code.
So all of this, essentially, is
declared with a  single line of
code.  And the data class over
here when  I add the data modify
ier to it, what essentially that
is  doing is providing me with
some new functionality,  namely
it's giving me equals, the hash
code, the two  string, and the
copy, which we'll see in a
moment.
What you also notice here is
that essentially I'm  doing the
whole property decoration and
constructor also  in a single
line.  So here I'm declaring two
properties.   One of them is
read only.  The others are read,
write.   And that in turn is
also creating a constructor.
That's  the short syntax.  You
could also do this in a longer
syntax.  One thing to notice if
you're not familiar with  Kotlin
is we don't have fields and
such.  We just have  properties.
And then you access these
properties with  accessers.
There's no set.  There is, but
it's under  the cover speed.
When you talk Java to Kotlin,
you get  the Java to Kotlin,
Kotlin to Java, you get the
approach  in each language.  But
if you're just working with
Kotlin, you can just use them
directly.  So I can say,  for
example, Val customer equals
customer Kotlin, and  then this
will be one A, B, and then your
customer dot  e-mail equals
something.  Okay?
A lot of boilerplate you're
saving there.  Now,  one thing
you also have is the copy class.
So here, you  can see that I
have a data class context, and
then a  list type e-mail.  And
if you do a copy context, it's
going to copy everything for you
; right?  So you're  going to
get all of those different
properties, and you  can, in
fact, overwrite and say I want
the company name  to be -- when
I copy, I want, for example, the
company  name to be something
else, and then it will -- and
then  it will default the other
ones to whatever the value is.
So you can overwrite the values
.  Okay?
We use data classes, as you know
, we like data  classes.
Initially, we have two poles,
and we got rid  of them because
one of the key aspects of Kotlin
is to  write maintainable code.
Now, we can't guarantee that
because, you know, we are
developers, and we can take  any
language and make it completely
unreadable.
And  there's a difference
between every coder's readable.
The different issue is whether
it's comprehensible,  which is
where we basically struggle.
But we do have pairs and triples
; right?  So, for  instance,
let's say that I have a function
that returns  pairs, so I just
basically I can just return a
pair of  type of string, string,
and we also have triples.  So
if  you go beyond triple, then
we say for you to use a data
class.  So here I can just do
pair, something else;  right?
Now, if I call this function,
how do I access  those
properties?  Well, the first one
is with first.   And guess what
the second one's going to be?
There you  go.  You are really
interactive, aren't you?
Anyway, so the second one is
going to be second.   Now, that
kind of sucks because, hey,
we're talking  about readability
, comprehensiveability, and what
is  first, what is second?  So
you have destructuring  variable
.  So you can do, for example,
name and e-mail  and then do
list as return pair; right?  And
now I can  access those in a
much more nicer way, giving me
context  and meaning of what
exactly it is that I'm accessing
.   So I can do print, line,
e-mail.  And this where you're
working with data classes, you
get when you're working  with
pairs, you get when you're
working with Lambdas,  and
notice here it says you're not
actually using name.   So that
is a hint that the compiler is
doing surfaceing.   What you can
also do is use the underscore.
And say  anything I don't use,
I'll just use underscore for and
get rid of all of those hints.
But more importantly, tell the
developer that's  reading this
code that this value is not
important.  And  as I said, this
destructuring can work with
anything.   So, for instance, we
have contacts or e-mail class,
so I  can say this is the name,
name one, and this is the
e-mail one, and then do exactly
the same for e-mail;  right?  So
I can say something.  Okay?
So it's not only with pairs, it
also works with  data classes.
And it's basically following the
convention of the first
parameter, the first position,
the second parameter, second
position, so on and so  fourth.
Where else do we try to improve
on the boilerplate  code that
you write?  So how many of you
love design  patterns?  Okay.
Don't be ashamed.
Single turn.  Let's  see.
Single turn in Java; right?  Now
, this is single  turn in Java,
which is fantastic.  Not
advocating the  use of single,
I'm just saying this is a single
in Java.   And let's take a
look at the singleton in Kotlin.
That's a singleton in Kotlin
because we essentially have
objects.  So much like in normal
languages you have a  class, a
type, and then you create an
instance of that  type.  In
JavaScript, you only have
objects, and then  you try to
mimic everything you learn from
another  language and bring
classes into JavaScript.  In
Kotlin,  we have both.  We have
objects, it just represents the
single value, and classes.
So here, I can just create an
object, which is a  single
Kotlin, and it has a property,
and of course I  can access this
by just saying singleton Kotlin
, and  property; right?  And
then assign a value.  No, you
don't assign a value to global
things.  You don't have  single
ton things you change values on.
That's kind of a  no-no.  For
read only, though, it's kind of
nice.  And  notice I'm not
advocating and saying, well,
since Kotlin  makes singleton so
easy, let me just create single
tons  throughout my entire code
base.  Nope, not saying that
either.
What else?  One thing we added
to Kotlin was the  concept of a
type value.  So here I have, for
instance,  the data class, and
I have a name, customer name,
and  e-mail.  Now, notice the
customer name is the same thing
as a string; right?  But it's
providing me with more
semantics.  Here I have -- and I
have done that using  this
thing over here called custom --
type custom string string.
Meaning that this property is
actually a type  string.  But to
provide more meaning, to
provide more  semantics, I'm
using the name customer name.
But I can  pass in it, will
verify this run time, this
string, you  can pass string
where it's customer name, et
cetera,.
Now, this comes in useful,
actually, sometimes  combining
this type with something else,
the annotation.   And I'll show
you how this works.  So let's
say that I  have a class,
customer, and we're going to not
come here here.  And I'm going
to rename this -- actually, I
just  comment it out.  And what
I've done here is essentially
created a deprecated annotation
that comes with Kotlin  and say
customer called customer and
this eventually  doesn't work.
It will be implemented so that
you can do  alt enter.  And
notice I'm saying customer is
awesome  customer; right?  So
now what happens here it says
awesome customer deprecated, and
you should use customer
instead; right?
Now, the good thing about that
is that this allows  you to re
factor things and rename things
without  potentially breaking
people's codes.  But then you're
probably thinking why do I
care about breaking people's
code?  Let me just do that
myself.
So it is actually quite useful
in that sense, and  we use it
quite a bit.  You can do
multiple face change.   Rename
something, and then issue a
warning, and then on  the next
one, I will remove that
deprecated and away we  go.
Nobody can complain because
that's -- you don't  complain as
developers.
So -- that was a joke.
Here's another example.  Of
course, it's not funny  when you
say that was a joke.  I have
condition  expressions Kotlin
and conditional expressions here
;  right?  So for now, let's
just focus on this one and the
action closest one, and I have a
string parameter.  So  I'm
comparing the string and zero,
assign a parameter to  it.  If
not, whatever.  I've got another
case where I'm  returning a
value, and then I've got a
switch statement  where I'm
saying if it's case one, if it's
case two.  If  not, then if the
value is within a specific
range, then  do this, et cetera,
.  Ignore that, it's going to
say, oh,  it's always going to
be true or false.  But for the
case  of this demo, it doesn't
matter.
So what about Kotlin?  Where do
we kind of try to  improve here?
Well, the first thing that you
can see is  that an if and a
when in Kotlin is an expression.
So  can I don't have -- well,
it can be treated as an
expression or a statement.  But
I don't have to  explicitly
declare a variable, assign that
variable  based on the actual
branch.  I can just return that
as  the result of the expression
.  This is a single line of
expression.  If I have multiple
lines, curly brackets,  then the
last line of that branch is
going to be the  return value.
So here I'm doing value can be
one, 20,  or I can write
multiple statements and then the
last  value is going to be the
return value.  I could even
return a string here; right?
But if I return a string,  the
compiler's going to give me a
warning and say  conditional
branch is returning the type
string, so I'm  casting the
return type to any.  Any is the
top-level  object in Kotlin;
right?  Meaning that if you want
to,  you can return a different
type branch.  Why would you
want to?  I don't know.  But you
can do it.  Well, there  are
cases, obviously.
Now, in a when statement,
similar to a case, but  we do
allow pattern match.  So you can
see I have one, I  have two,
which we had in Java case, and
then I have a  bunch of values
three, four, five.  I can even
check  whether it's a type, I
can even check whether it's in a
range, and I can even call a
function and have the  function
calculate the value and return
whether that's a  true or false
statement; right?
Point being what?  It is very
similar in code to  what you've
seen in Java.  Difference being
that it's  saving you a lot of
pain when you're writing this
code.   Okay?  It's allowing you
to be more concise, more
expressive.  And that's
essentially what Kotlin is about
about.  It's not about a single
feature that you look at  and
say okay.  This is cool.  But I
can do this in Java.   You can
do everything in Java.  And when
I say Java, I  mean you can do
everything in assembly.  How
many of you  here program in
Assembly?  Three people.
Awesome.
Still?
Right.  Now, another thing
that we try to  help with is
Java.  This is your typical
example; right?   If customers
don't know, if customer's name
is don't  know, if customer's
Git name starts with blah, blah,
blah, how do we solve this
program?  We do, but we don't
don't.  Well, we do but I'll
tell you.  We -- yes.   Anyway,
by default, we don't have types.
So when you  declare a type in
Kotlin; right?  If I can't hear
, and I  say my strength equals
some value, and then I do my
strength equals null, that's not
going to work because  it says
this type is not nullable; right
?  If I  initialize it to null,
then it will work.  You can also
do explicit type decoration in
Kotlin, but you normally  don't
, so I do string, that is going
to give an error  because string
is not nullable.  And one day I
will  write something, probably
.
Now, what I can do to make this
nullable is add a  question mark
and say this is now nullable;
right?  So I  can assign a null
able type to it.  Why would you
want to  do this?  Again, try to
move away from nullable types.
In Kotlin by default, you
don't declare nullable types.
However, we -- one of the
purposes of creating Kotlin  was
to be able to interrupt with
all of the existing  Java code
that we have and you have.  And
when you're  interrupting with
Java, you're going to face null
able  types.  So you need to
have that question mark there
sometimes to be able to
interrupt nullable types.  So in
the case of Kotlin what we're
trying to do is make it a
little bit nicer to work with.
So here, you see that  basically
the same kind of code -- in
this case, I don't  have to do
any checks because it's a custom
Kotlin, and  I'm saying that
it's not nullable.  Okay?
In this case, however, given
that this is coming  from Java,
I can actually explicitly say
that this is  going to be a null
able type by adding a question
mark.   Since I say it's going
to be a nullable type, then
Kotlin, I would have to do kind
of, like, in line of if
customer is not null, then do
something with it.  You  can do
a much shorter syntax with that
by just using the  question mark
here.  So that's basically
saying if  customer is not null,
then if name is not null, then
it  starts with blah, blah, blah
, and if that equals true,  then
do something.  Okay?
So when you're working with Java
, you have to  decide whether
the type you're actually working
with is  nullable or not.  I
could actually remove this and
say  there you go.  I now know
that this will never be null.
So you could use the not null
annotations that different
libraries provide, which kind of
recognize whether  that's going
to be nullable or not.  What
you can't do  is remove that and
then get null reference
exception run  time and then say
, well, didn't Kotlin say remove
null?   No, because you're
explicitly saying that this is
null.
And as I always say, if you
really want to be  brave, what
you can also do is declare this
as nullable,  and then do
customer double exclamation ID
and that  means I don't care.  I
missed my null reference, I
just  want you to blow up at run
time.  Okay?
So you can do that as well.  Why
you add that?   Don't start --
this is one of the main things
that  people fall into.  The
trap when they start to port
over  their Java code, initially
they're, like, oh, well, this
is null, what should I do?
Double exclamation.  No, you
don't.
Not having null in the language
is actually  forcing you to
think more essentially; right?
Because  it's not a happy path.
Normally when we do error
control, well, if it's not null,
I'll do this.  And if  it's
null, I'll pretend that nobody
saw anything.  Now  it's kind of
saying what happens if it's not
null?  Well Well, I don't know.
So what else?  One of the things
in Kotlin is  extension
functions; right?  So what I can
essentially  do is do fun,
string, Krakow, and what that
will do is  is -- essentially --
print line Krakow is great.
Okay?   So now I can say Poland
and Krakow
are great.  Okay?  So  I've
just added a new function to
crack out are great.   It's only
done crack crack out
Krakow.  I can extend any type
in Kotlin  or Java; right?
So you're kind of thinking why
would I want to do  this?  Again
, to make code expressive.  Now,
I normally  wouldn't do -- add
a function in my code base
called  Krakow, we could do
something like case with
inverted  German style; right?
I could do something like that;
right?  Because you know in
Germany they do inverted  things
; right?
So this gives you, again,
expressiveity.  I don't  have to
take a string class and inherit
it from it, add  a new method
to be able to just add one more
function.   Okay?  This is where
the beauty of this extension
functions are.  And if you
actually look at the standard
library, which you'll see in a
moment, most of the
functionality you get are, in
fact, extension function  over
generic types, meaning that you
get a whole bunch  of
functionality independently of
the type of things  that you use
.  Whether it's strings, whether
it's  collections, et cetera,.
Okay?  And we'll see that when
we take a look at Lambdas.
Now, Lambdas in Java, I have
Lambdas in Java.  If  I want to
declare something in Java that's
a high-order  function, I can
say, well, I can do it in two
ways.  I  could define an inter
face that takes two parameters,
or  I can do something like a by
consumer or a by function  or a
whatever, and then have all of
these different  types, and then
passing the parameters that I
need, and  then the ID it will
say to me.  Okay.  This is a
Lambda.   You don't have to
implement, you can just pass
this in  as a Lambda just like
I'm using like using list on
Java;  right?  Here, I'm
creating a new instance, but I
can re replace that with Lambda.
You can do pretty much the
same  thing in Kotlin; right?
Except, you don't have to have
the specific type decoration,
you can just pass in  Lambda
like that, and you will see that
this is omitting  the brackets
like in a moment.
But how do I declare high order
function?   Essentially, we're
using always the same syntax.  I
don't have to know about by
bifunctions or anything like
that.  This is a function that
takes two interests and  returns
an integer.  Here is a function
that takes no  parameters and
returns void.  All right?
Technically,  it's not a
function, but anyway.
So always following the same
syntax.  Always.  And  now I can
pass as a Lambda.  And when you
want to invoke  it, you do
higher order, and you actually
pass in the  Lambda, which is
this syntax.  And the same the
last  parameter to a function is
another function, then I can
omit; right?  And then what I
can do is make this multi
multiline, which will make it a
little bit nicer.  And  you say
why?  Well, then I could do
something like this.   I could
take a greater function using,
for instance,  object, which is
closeable, and then have a body.
Basically, what it's doing is
going to invoke the body.   And
then I'll do finally, object
close; right?  And then  what I
could do, imagine that I have
about closeable  thing here,
whatever, will close it,
whatever imagine  that that
works, and then I could do using
closeable,  and then not have
to worry about that resource
being  free.  Using is a
statement that we have in C#,
and you  have a similar tribe of
resources.  But essentially
giving
you that fluid key of feeling
as if you are  adding
functionality to the language in
a way that is  very expressive
and easy to read and understand.
Okay?
And all of these functions as I
mentioned, we have have, like,
when working with functions, all
of these  things are part of
the standard library.  So, by
the way way, this is how you
create a list of numbers in
Kotlin  one to 100, and then on
the numbers, I could do things
like filter, it is less than 100
.  So it is following  the same
syntax as groovey saying that
the function I  pass in as a
single parameter, I don't have
to  explicitly name that
parameter.  So instead of doing
something like X and then X is
less than 100, I can  actually
convert into using implicit.
Okay?  And then I  could change
these.  Map
get 100 or what have you.
So these functions, as I mention
, they're  basically part of the
standard library, you can see
the  extension function.  So I
have all the functionality,  all
the different types of
collections that I want to  use.
And Kotlin doesn't provide
right now collection,  basically
interface it on top of Java's
collection by  default moving
towards immutable.  So when I do
, for  instance, customers
equals all, and then a customer
Kotlin, that is going to create
an immutable customer  for me
in Kotlin, and I can add a
second one, customer  Kotlin,
and then whatever I want.  Okay?
One other thing, difference with
Java is that like  in Java, you
would
have the Java strings.  So the
equivalent of what I did is one
, 100 is inth string.   The
difference in Kotlin, all of
these lists are equally
evaluated.  If you want to do
evaluation, what you do is  just
write ask sequence, and you
could do that to any  collection
; right?  And if you want to do
to something a  little bit more
complex than a collection, you
do top  level sequence, and then
pass in a C and then generate
the code that you want to and
then on that, map it to --
filter it, it is less than 100,
and then for each, and  then
here print line, et cetera,.
Okay?  One other thing  that
we've tried to, again, focusing
on it is just more  compact,
more concise, easier to read.
Another thing  that we have,
which is kind of nice is the
return types.   Our way of
implementing algebraic data
types, which is  kind of useful
where you essentially say a type
, a  function, for instance, is
returning one type or another
another.
A type can be one type or
another.  The way  that we
represent that in Kotlin is
essentially through  a hierarchy
of classes.  But then what we
do is add the  C modifyier,
which essentially means that
this hierarchy  is closed.
Meaning that nobody else can
ever inherit  from response;
right?  And these are inside, I
can  actually take them outside
and then have something, like
like, failure, success, and
response.  And then get rid  of
all of these things.  And notice
-- I don't know if  you see it
there, but this has gone green;
right?  This  has gone green
because that's another thing
that we have  in Kotlin, which
is smart pass.  Which
essentially means  saving having
to type things over and over
again.  And  instead of casting
these success, I can just assume
that  it is success because the
compiler has done that.  So
these are some of the things
that Kotlin has done to be  able
to let you work more concisely
and more fluently  and more
rapidly and more fun.  Thank you
.
[Applause]
THIS IS A CAPTION TEST.  THIS
IS A CAPTION TEST.
Test.  Test.  This is a caption
test.  Please standby for
realtime captions.  Testing
testing one two three.  This is
a caption test.  Please standby
for realtime
Test.  This is a captioning
test.
me see if the
paragraph still works? Nope,
I'm going to have to redefine
it.
Now let's test it.  Testing
testing one two
And what does the paragraph
look like? Test.  Test.
Does it clear my screen now?
And now the definition
is there.  There is quite a
delay.
this is.
Test.  This is a caption test.
Please standby for realtime
captions.  Testing testing one
two three four five six seven.
Test.  Test.  Test.
testing the closed captioning.
Testing testing testing.  This
is a caption
Test.
Hello everybody.  How's it
going? Having a good day so far?
with another talk? Cool! Okay.
Let's get going.  We're going
to do -- I hope
zero to app.  We're going to be
building a universal translator
with cloud base right in front
of your very eyes.  It takes
three of us to build an app all
together.  I'm going to be doing
a lot of the talking and some
of the coding.  Joining me is
Hi, I'm
that, let me tell you a story.
Everybody likes story time,
right? I like story time.  I'm
going to tell you a story about
science fiction.  I love sci-fi.
Any other a fans in the
of my favorites is star trek.
One of the things that makes it
so awesome is all of the
different technology that's in
the show.  For example, we have
the captain, who can ask a
computer with his own voice for
a cup of tea, and the computer
will respond by making it
magically appear.  And although
we can't make tea appear from
air yet, we're actually making
good progress on a lot of Star
Trek technology.  You can use
things like Google
cool technology from Star Trek
was the universal translator.
The team would beam down on some
foreign world and encounter
some alien race they had never
seen before.  And within the
first couple words they uttered,
they were instantly able to
communicate
is a technology that I would
love to
bit to do things like give
talks, but I'm one of those
mono-lingual people.  I can only
speak one language.  I'm
ashamed.  It would be great if I
could communicate with people
in their preferred language more
easily.  So we're going to
solve that problem using the
technique we use to solve all
the problems in our life, which
is
we're going to build mobile
apps.  We want to work with
everyone, regardless of their
specific preferred language or
platform.  So we want this to
work on iOs and Android.  This
is where Firebase
Traditionally, we would have
some challenges, because we
would probably want to spin up a
big
cluster, maybe a post REST
there.  Probably wire them into
some cool back-end APIs to pick
up some of the heavy lifting,
but we
a different approach.  This is
where Firebase can help us get a
lot in motion quickly.
Firebase gives us, both in
addition to all sorts of cool
back-end stuff, gives us a bunch
of client libraries, and easy
bindings to make it easier than
ever to build stuff
can think about Firebase is
it's my big bag of app
development goodies.  There are
all sorts of things to make my
app and web development easier.
Hosting and deep
dynamic languages and crash
reporting.  We're just going to
focus on a few of the different
goodies.  We're going to talk
about cloud storage for
Firebase.  We're going to talk
about authentication, and
realtime database.  So let's dig
into each one of these a little
bit deeper.  First, cloud
storage for Firebase.  A lot of
modern applications have to move
binary chunks of stuff like
bios.  Youing might have to
upload photos or some recorded
audio that you want to move
around.  And Firebase for cloud
storage makes this a lot easier,
because you have cool client
libraries, and you don't have to
think much about it.  You just
send your data off to the
clients can automatically
access that binary data really
advantage of all the cool
infrastructure that Google
provides super fast, network,
high reliability, all of the
stuff that you have
Okay.  Now we have all of our
biostuff dealt with.  Next we
want to
handle authentication.
Authentication is important.
You want to control a little
bit.  You want to make sure that
only those of us on stage can
write data into our universal
translator.  Some of you might
want to play some trickery on
us, so we will use Firebase for
that.  Has anybody ever wrote
their own authentication from
scratch? A couple people.  It's
really kind of a pain whether
you're doing e-mail and password
log-in.  You have to make sure
you're doing the right hashing.
Or if you're working with a
provider, and there's a lot
there that we seem to do
authentication takes the parts
of that and gives you easy
bindings to client libraries.
One of the
cool things about Firebase is
that you -- all of your users
have a single identifier that
you can use to identify them
across your application.  Okay.
So we have authentication taken
care
comes in, the realtime database
is awesome.  This is how it
works.  So it is kind of like a
big old ball of JSON in the sky.
We like JSON,
great.  You take any of your
data
that you could represent as
JSON, text, all of that stuff.
You have them write on a big
tree of JSON.  This is where the
magic comes in.
of having to deal with network
asynchronous stuff, have your
clients tell Firebase what node
or what sub tree or even a query
against a sub tree in that JSON
blob that they care about.
client libraries take care of
calling your function whenever
there's a change.  We take care
of validation and handling
online and offline network
blips.  It handles it for you,
and it's
time, but you're here to see
some code, right? We're going to
build the apps right now.  I'm
going to hand it over to Bret,
who's going to help guide us
through the
are we going to live-code an
app in front of you today, we're
going to live code two apps.
We have Kathy who will be
working on the iOS version, and
Jen who will be working on the
Android version.
here? So we've got a language
picker.  This is going to set
the language that is my
preferred language.  This will
be both the language that I'm
speaking into the app, and also
the language that out here is
spoken back to me as messages
come in.  Messages can be coming
in from any language and their
point of origin, but when it
gets to me, it will be
translated out loud into my
preferred language.  You'll hit
the record button.  It will
create an audio file local on
your device.  What we will code
in front of you is how to upload
that to the cloud, do the
processing, and turn the
translation
code.  We have preconfigured the
apps.  We have fleshed out the
UI and used
create an instance to the
Firebase off service,
have those references, we're
going to prep some data,
including the file to be
uploaded, before we actually do
the upload.  We're going to get
two references.  One is where
we're going to upload the file,
which would be under
that we're going to up load
this data.  We're going to set
some meta data.  Specifically,
we'll set the audio file type.
AMR for Android and linear 16
for iOS.  Once we have that data
set, let's perform the upload.
Firebase's click file, which
gives us a couple of listener
options.  If something goes
wrong, we're going to show the
user that the upload failed.  In
the case of success, we will
have a listener that takes
metadata, specifically the type
of encoding, the language of
origin, and the location of
cloud storage, and we're going
to write this.  Because we're
writing it to the realtime
database, this will enable all
of our clients to, in realtime,
get updates when something
happens.  That's actually all
the code that we need.  Let's
see a demo.  Fire this up in
right.  Let's try iOS.
English.  I'm going to make a
recording.  Hello
no.  It says failed to upload
audio with
Our first demo failure of the
day.  We want to see this error
message.  That's because we have
no authentication and our
Firebase, our cloud storage is
secure.  There are two ways to
get around the error.  The
first, which I know a lot of you
do, is open it up for everyone.
and write to your storage
bucket.  But that's not what
we're going to do.  We're going
to put authentication on your
app to make sure that not
everybody on the internet is
uploading files.  What could
possibly go wrong? We will set
up the auth flow.  If the user
is not authenticated, we will
use Firebase UI, which is an
open source library, that has
social flows for all of your
providers like Google, Twitter,
Facebook, and so forth.  It is
UI out of the box that is
configureable, so you can get an
out-of-the-box UI that is
configureable with very little
effort.  Let's try the demo
again and hopefully get a little
better results.  With just a
few lines of code, we're
enabling
now I'll sign in.
As prompted.  And once I've
signed in, make another
recording.
Kathy.  Now to prove that
wasn't a trick, we actually did
an upload.  Jen's got a console
here in Firebase.  You can see
that it has the data about the
file we just uploaded, like the
encoding type, file type, and
also the location in cloud
storage.  Let's actually go to
cloud storage and see the file
that we've just created when
Kathy recorded her voice.
to Jen's local workstation.
We'll put it into our audio
player so you can actually hear
recording and uploading
successfully.  There's only one
more thing that we need to add
to our client.  When the
translation happens, we need to
display that in the client and
play the text out loud.  Let's
do that now.  Pop back over to
our code.  We're going to do a
couple things.  We're going to
connect to the Firebase realtime
database.  We're going to
listen on the translations node
on the JSON tree.  We have a
translation node and every time
something comes in, it gets a
new child node under that.  It's
all asynchronous.  As they're
getting translated, it pop
pop lates it.  We're going to
have a second listener just
way if we're listening for
English, and it gets finished
first, then our app will get
updated
take the text that comes back
from Firebase, and we're going
to pipe it to our update and
play method here in our app,
which actually uses
text-to-speech within the
Android and iOS apps to play
that out loud.  Let's actually
load up the demo again.  And all
right.  So the piece we don't
have yet is the part that
actually takes the audio file,
listens to it, turns it into
text, and then translates that
into another language.  But we
actually do have that
technology.  So we've got some
Gen powered translation.  So
what Jen's going to do is
manually listen to the audio
file, go into the Firebase
database, add a child under the
translation
object, and put in her desired
translation: English in this
case.  You can see that it shows
I'm concerned, we have the
pieces we need.  Audio files
recording, uploading, Jen doing
the listening
know, everything is good.  So
that's a problem.  So if you
need any translation between the
hours 11:00 p.m. and 7:00 a.m.,
unfortunately our service will
be offline.  If only there were
some buzzword that could do some
of this for us.  Maybe
something like machine learning.
Let's bring Kathy out and she
will talk to us about how we can
solve this using Machine
Learning.
avoid the problem of Jen having
to manually translate all of
our recordings, we're going to
plug in some software.  It would
be a cool project to design and
train our own Machine Learning
models, that would take longer
than we want now, as we want to
quickly get this app up and
running.  So that's
where we go to Google Cloud
machine learning pretraining
APIs.  There are a set to solve
common use cases such as image
recognition, and in this case,
we'll pick the two that are for
our app.  So we be using the
cloud speech API to transcribe
audio recording into text, and
then translation API to
translate among all the
different languages.  So now do
we have all the components to
make our app work? Seems like
are we going to wire these cool
cloud APIs into our app?
Traditionally with Firebase
apps, you would bake everything
into the client, which is great
because it's serverless.  But we
do run into a few challenges
that many apps will come across
as they scale.  For example,
your
our case, we have API keys that
will be used with those two
cloud APIs, and may have some
pre-release feature flagged code
packaged with your app that is
possibly discoverable by users.
logic that's
resource-incensive.  Our end
user devices could have their
battery drain quickly by
performing all of these
translations.  And building
mobile applications across
platforms often requires writing
logic multiple times.  We would
prefer to avoid that, if
possible.  Our app has all of
these challenges, but we can
mitigate them by moving our API
secrets and resource-intensive
code into the cloud, where we
can write the translation logic
once and have it work for
Android and iOS apps.  What
might that actually look like,
though? You might think first of
something like this, where you
spin up some compute instances
that will trigger APIs.  But
there's actually some complexity
to that.  As you scale, you'll
have to deal with load
balancing, caching, rapid
requests to your various
servers.  And soon you may end
up actually managing something
that looks like this, which is
more complexity than
Google, we've been helping to
manage your app architecture
stress for a long time.
Google Cloud platform started
with AppEngine in 2008, the
original platform as a service.
And while a lot has changed
since then, we've built on our
decade of experience providing
compute solutions for your apps
to deliver the right solution
for our use case.  So now,
instead of this, we'll actually
use cloud function, which will
serve as the glue for our
serverless app.  Now we have a
new recipe that looks like this
where we'll put our app keys
into our CloudFunctions and any
other secrets.  Have that be
research intensive, and then
write the fmt and have them
execute the logic for both
mobile apps.  Now Bret will show
us
get started, it's actually
pretty simple.  We have a few
variables up top that include
our credentials for using cloud
APIs as well as a function set
here.  And then we'll start with
our first cloud function, which
you specify trigger that
invokes the function, which in
this case would be a new upload
of the audio recording to the
Firebase realtime database, and
we listen on the upload node.
And when we get a new upload in
that sub tree, we will pull some
meta data from it, and then
make a call to the cloud speech
API to get the transcript of the
text.  And we send along the
location in cloud storage of the
actual binary data of the audio
recording.  When we get back,
the transcript will write it
back to the realtime database
under transcripts to set us up
for the next part, which is
translation.  For translation,
we'll create a second cloud
function, this time listening to
the translation sub tree in the
realtime database.  Upon
getting a new transcript
written, it will take that and
it rate through all the
languages that our app supports
and for each language make a
call to the translation API, get
the translation and write it
back to our realtime database
under translation.  At the end,
process all of our languages and
signal that our function is
complete.  At this point, we
have all the logic that we need
to make our app work.  And all
we have left is to deploy the
function, which is pretty
straightforward with a Firebase
deploy command, you can deploy
all the functions that you've
written.  It might take a couple
minutes, and we have precious
time here.  We have done the
deployment.  This is what it
looks like.  I'll hand it back
to Jen to show us what the
working translation app looks
need all of your help.  Those
of you here present, and those
of you on the internet, via the
live stream, I know you all have
some kind of computing device
with you, and many of those
contain web browsers.  Go to
this URL on your computing
thing.  If you want to be extra
awesome, turn your volume up a
little bit, maybe all
there won't be a rickroll or
anything like
our app.  So we're going to go
back over to see our app with
everything together.  So I'm
going to switch over to the one
that's wired up to the
CloudFunctions, and we're going
to give it a spin.  I mentioned
that I'm a mono
language
another language and see it
translate.  There's my terrible
attempt at a foreign language.
Let's see.  So it's uploaded and
it's up in the cloud doing the
translation.
languages.  If we switch to
English and we see good morning,
baby.  Okay.  So my Japanese is
not that good.  Anybody want to
give me a reply
I do have a reply to you, Jen.
I will switch the language
picker to yet another language,
and here we go.
Speaking
should be triggering.
know how to say good morning,
kind
of people in the audience using
it, and I heard a lot of
syllables in languages that I
don't understand.  How did it
translate? Did anybody pick
anything other than English,
French,
of.  It's
that in
our next version.  But, I think
it's time for
take a little
peek at what we did the last 20
minutes or so.  We went in with
a plan to help us translate and
more easily communicate with
people all over the world.  And
how we solved all of or problems
in life, by writing mobile
apps.  We wrote two apps.  We
wrote an Android and iOS app.
Once those were built, we also
built out a back end to connect
those all together and to
connect into third-party APIs.
So whereas in the past you might
have built something like this,
which we could not have
possibly done in a half hour
session.  But we have a new
arrow in our quiver with
Firebase.  We're able to connect
all of the single and in
between apps together and using
the various backend services and
taking it a step firther with
cloud services.  This allows us
to take advantage of all of the
cool stuff that Firebase has to
offer and connect it to third
party APIs out there, whether
they be APIs Google Cloud
platform or your own vendors or
home brew APIs.  Here's where I
have a challenge
you have another arrow in your
quiver that you can use to solve
all of your app problems.  I
would challenge you to use this
formula and tell us about what
you've built.  We love hearing
from you.  So go ahead, build
stuff, and then let us know how
it goes.  We'd love to hear from
you about questions, concerns,
and just awesome stuff you want
to
you.  DMs are definitely
welcome.  We'd love feedback on
our section as well.  Scan our
QR code or go to the URL at the
bottom of the page and
>> Hello, everybody, I'm James
Daniel developer  relations with
Firebase.  And I'm here to talk
to you  about all of the things
that you can do with Cloud
Functions for Firebase.  So to
set the stage for my talk talk,
I would like to talk about what
you could do in  the good ol'
days before Firebase.  So a
traditional  application, you
would interact with a
intermediate  server with API.
Maybe this application, this API
server is written in Rail,
maybe express.  It handles  all
of your server authentication
project.  Server,  secrets, all
of that proprietary stuff, as
well as all  the busy work,
computationally intense work.
But it  can't
that's where Firebase comes in,
and giving this  talk, I hope
you're at least familiar with
Firebase.  So  Firebase
applications.  We've written an
SDK for you, in
iOS, Android, mobile Web, and
a lot of other frameworks,  and
that SDK communicates to the
Firebase service.   There is no
intermediate intermediary
gatekeeper.  Google handles all
of
that for you with a suite of
tools that are called  directly
from the SDK itself.  Very
powerful manage  services that
allow you to go on building an
app, rather  than working on all
the boiler boilerplate.  So we
have  authentication, we have
our realtime database, we have
cloud messages, and lots of more
products there.  And  really,
it's to empower you to deliver
products faster  without
worrying about all the DevOps
and stuff like  that.
There's also a realtime
database.  How this is
differentiated from a
traditional database is the
realtime database syncnizes sync
synchronizes all the changes in
milliseconds.  And this allows
you to build very rich
applications for free with
Firebase.  None of this, you
know, having to spin up servers
and juggle sockets and  lots of
complicated things.  So nice
little addition to  the Firebase
product.  And if you are to
build your own  servers, you
would have to build all of that
as well.   But there are
problems in this thick client
model
promoted by Firebase.  Not
without its disadvantages;
right?  So while Firebase gives
you a very powerful tool  to
validate the data coming to your
database to validate  the users
writing, reading files, this is
our rules  engine, there are
things that you can't quite do
in  Firebase without Cloud
Functions.  So say you wanted to
perform an expensive operation
.  You want to resize an  image
or transcode a video, this is
something that would  burn up
your user's battery, very likely
to uninstall  your application
if you do that, and just, you
know,  it's going to make your
application slower.  And, again,
it's just a lot of complexity.
It's just shifting that
complexity to the clients.  So
now you need to know how  to re
size an image on iOS, Android,
and then you're  going to have
to do it on the Web for all
kinds of trick trickery.  So say
you didn't want to trust the
client.   The realtime database
has a very powerful rule step
but  can't encapsulate
everything in there.  Say you
wanted  to moderate images.
Say you wanted to filter out the
language.  What if you have
secrets, what if you have
private keys, API tokens?
Things you don't want on the
client.  Clients can't be
trusted; right?  It's just an
application on their phone.  It
can be cracked open.   They can
look at the secrets.  They can
grab those.  So  you don't want
to put things like your push
notification  secrets in there
to allow peer to peer messaging.
That  would be leaking this
and somebody could crack the
application, grab that secret,
and message your users in  mass.
That's no good.
Say you have a proprietary
algorithm and act with  a third
party or maybe you need to
expose a classic HTTP  end point
.  These are all things that are
hard to do on  Firebase.  So in
the good ol' days, you'll say
this was  easier.  You know, my
server, it's mine, I control it,
I  can make whatever APIs I
want.  I can do whatever I want
to do on there.  So why don't
we combine them?  So say  we
attach generic computes to
Firebase, just using it as  a
regular old client.  So it's
listening to changing the
database, it's then writing into
the database.  In fact,  until
recently, this was pushed as a
best practice to  the Firebase
team with tools like Firebase Q
where you  would write into part
of the database things that you
wanted these listening clients
to do, these workers.   But now
you have this problem again.
Now you have these  workers,
these generic compute, you have
to scale them,  you have to pay
for the excess capacity, and
then you're  going to have all
kinds of trouble coming
around where,  oh, what if two
workers are doing the same job?
Then  you're going to have a
lot of bike shedding about the
way the realtime Firebase
database.  And wasn't Firebase
supposed to make all of this
easy, after all?  It  promised
to make us deliver applications
faster and now  where you're
bike shedding, talking about how
to scale  these workers and now
we need to spin
up a DevOps team,  it's no good
.  So that's why recently the
Firebase team  launched Cloud
Functions into beta.  So how
Cloud  Functions for Firebase
works is instead of spinning up
general compute and teaching it
to Firebase, we have  event-
driven code execution.  It will
scale up with your  usage, and
then down to zero not when in
use.  And  you're only paying
for those milliseconds that you
use.   This allows us to provide
that allows you to stitch all
of Firebase's products together.
So I mentioned event driven.  So
what this is is  you actually
write snippets of code that
listen to an  event -- this is
Node.js code.  Those functions
are each  isolated, they're all
running separately.  So if one
of  them crashes, it doesn't
take down the other.  And
Windows events come in, it will
execute that code, and  it will
either
write back to the database or
trigger  some other action.  So
you can do things like listen to
a database write.  Then the
code can sanitize the input  and
write to another spot on the
database.
So let's see this in action.
All right.  So here's a very
minimal example.   This is
probably the basic example every
time you see  something, we
have a hello world function here
.  So this  is a HTTP function.
This allows us to spin up.
This  function is actually in
the express JS style, and it
sends hello world.  So this is
an HTTP request.  It is
synchronous.  We don't want to
be doing Async work on  this.
We want to send a response as
quick as we can.
So let's jump to a more
complicated example.  So  here's
one where we're actually
listening to the  database.  So
up here, we're actually
initializeing  Firebase
functions and the admin, SDK,
for Firebase.   We're pulling in
the configuration and
initializeing  Firebase admin.
We're then listening on the
database,  this, and those are
wild cards.  Those will be
parsed  into our parameters.
And then on create means it's a
database insert.  Rather than
an update or destroy.  It  sends
an event object.  We pull the
current value, we  pull the user
name from that, the text, title
body, and  we send it to the
room ID on a FCM topic.  So what
does  this do?  When a message
is posted to a chat room, it
will notify through FCM push
notifications all  subscribers.
Regardless of platform; right?
This could  be iOS, this could
be Android, this could be the
Web.   And magically, they're
going to get this.  And very low
code.  We run this, this is an
independent function, we  just
deploy this.
And Google is going to handle
all of  the scaling up and
scaling down as needed.
So what type of things do we
have?  You already  saw the
HTTPS function.  That allows you
to send an  express JS response
.  This express JS object, it
doesn't  have to be as simple as
just that response send, you
can  actually create an express
JS application.  It could be
your full JSON API.
So where I had that hello world,
that will match  any path on
there.  So you could just have
exports API  and then give it an
express application that has
your  entire JSON API.  There's
also cloud triggers.  It  allows
you to do durable publish,
scribe.  Say, if you  do have a
server, you could be writing to
a pub/subqueue  and then have a
Node.js executed whenever
anything  triggers on that.
Cloud storage for Firebase.  So
when files are  uploaded, you
can perform operations on them.
Firebase  hosting.  So this
integration allows you when
you're  using Firebase ecstatic
Web base hosting to write proxy
calls.  So you can put in URL
pattern matches that will  re
direct you to cloud function.
So I mentioned the API kits.
There we go.  That  allows you
to take our static hosting and
make it  dynamic.  There's also
the Firebase realtime database,
as you saw.  And there's
Firebase authentication.  So
when users are created, you can
trigger code.  So a good  use
case for this is say you're
storing user settings or or --
in a realtime database, and you
want to set some  defaults there
.  Or you want to interact with
a third  party and say set up a
customer record in Stripe or
subscribe them to your mailing
list on SendGrid.  You  can
actually do this with that.  And
you can pull in  this third
party libraries.  I mentioned
those are  Node.js.  So you can
pull in these dependencies if
they  have a Node.js module
available on NPM.
And then there's Google
Analytics for Firebase.   So
those great Google Analytics
conversion vents, you  can
listen for them and trigger code
.  So say a user  does a NF
purchase, you could send them an
FCM saying  thank you or say in
the database, marking them as a
VIP  customer.  And there's
many more coming soon.  If
you're  interested in the
additional triggers that are
coming  with Cloud Functions for
Firebase, I recommend that you
join our alpha program.  So
Firebase.Google.com/alpha.
All right.  So I'm asking you to
take Cloud  Functions to your
customers.  It wouldn't really
be fair  if I wasn't willing to
embarrass myself on stage.  So
time for a live demo.
All right.  So what I've created
here is actually  an
integration with Twilio.  So
praying to the live demo  gods
that this will work.
So let's start by saying
hello.  It wants me to send
pictures.  Let's grab one  from
my Web camera.
Now let's see what it says.
It's  analyzing.  That's
promising.
Awesome. hair.  That's  what
it picked up.  Let's send it
another one.
Analyzing.  Music.  Cloud
vision didn't quite know what
to think of doc Brown.
So how did I accomplish this?
Let's show you the  code.
So here, I actually have my
Twilio messaging call  back.  So
what I've done here is create
an HTTPS trigger trigger, Twilio
messaging call back, I glanced
on this,  but that is actually
the root of the URL.  So it will
be  my Cloud Functions domain/
Twiliomessaging cele callback
will actually be the URL, and
that will be on that part,  so
this if you were setting up an
API, you could just do do/API,
pass an express application.
But in this case,  I'm just
going to define it all here.  So
I have an  HTTPS on request,
express JS.  So this is actually
a lot  of this code here is
just dealing with the format
that  Twilio is sending me.  So
I'm looking at the number of
pictures.  If it's zero, I say
send me pictures.  I'm  going to
create a payload because --
well, maybe the MMS MMSs were
back.  Maybe it sent more than
one at the same  time.  So I'm
going to insert these into the
realtime  database.  So here I
go.  I loop over them, add to
this  update payload, and then I
insert into the database
by  doing update, then I'm
sending Twilio ML.  So this is
actually an XML API.  And here,
you can actually see I  have a
little helper down here.
Response type XML, send send.
And then the XML there.
So that is actually inserting
into the database.   I'll
actually show you where those
are coming in.  So  there we
have the inbound MMS.  You can
see them coming  to the database
.  And I have a couple other if
parameters here that were not
for the Roman two URL that  I
set.  So those are coming in
from these pair of  functions.
So these functions here are
independent of  each other.
They're running in parallel.
They don't  know about each
other.  They're isolated.  So
here,  they're both listening to
an inbound MMS, and they're
listening for that insert.  So
what this is doing is  grabbing
the image URL, and it's using
the cloud vision  API.  So
that's just an N PM module that
I initialize.   And it's doing
label detection on those.  I
send it, the  image URI and the
format that the API wants, and
that's  a promise.  So I listen
for the result of that, Parse it
it, and then I write it to the
interface.  So this event  data
admin.  So these database writes
by default are  coming in
as the user who inserted them
into the  database.  So the
Firebase realtime database rules
will  respect that.  If I use
admin ref, then it's saying I
want to by bypass these rules.
This works in the context  of
Cloud Functions.  And admin
initialize.
So here I can actually bypass
the rules.  So my  database
rules if I wanted, I could
actually make it so  that label
annotations was actually not
writeable.  But  the admin short
circuit that.  And then, again,
so  that's grabbing the label
annotations, this is also off
of a safe search annotation.  So
what I'm doing there is  Parse
ening, whether or not it's safe
for work.
So if I go back to my realtime
database, we have  label
annotations.  So music, that's
where that came  from.
Performing arts, performance.
Well, I guess that  is
performing parts in a
arts in a performance; right?
Let's look  at our safe search
annotation.  So it's not very
likely  to the adult content and
unlikely to be violent.
So how did we actually then send
a response back  to the user?
So let's take a look at our code
.  So here  we go.  We're
actually responding to the MMS
with label.   So we're listening
to the database, this inbound M
MS  push ID on update.  So here
we're not just listening for
the insert.  We're listening for
whenever this node in  the
database is actually updated.
So we're pulling in  the current
value.  We're also pulling in
the previous  value.  Label
annotations.  And what I'm
looking for is  that the label
annotations are not null, and
that it  didn't previously have
label annotations.  So what I'm
doing there is listening for
the insert of the label
annotations.  From and to.  I
put together the body, and  then
the Twilio client messaging
create different body.
And here, I'm actually returning
because the  database ones
allow for asynchronous responses
.  So it  expects either a
promise return, hence the return
the  Twilio client messages
create, which is a promise, or
an  object.  That's the return
null.  If it doesn't return
either one of these, it's going
to be treated as an  error
condition.
So that is sent by the Twilio
client API, which is  just an N
PM library, and I actually
initialize it with  function
config, so there's actually run
time config  that you can set so
that your secrets are not in
your  code.
So we have this safe search
annotation.  Where  does that
come into play?  That's the last
function here here.  So here,
I'm also listening.  And what
I'm  looking for is, again, the
insertion of the safe search
annotation.  I'm looking at the
previous value.  So  label
annotations is null.  Safe
search, null, then  we're going
to return null.  Else, look for
it being un unlikely or very un
likely.  If it's either one of
those,  it short circuits and
goes back here.  So then, it
actually writes to a public
images route.  And there, I
have made a static website.
Where you can actually see these
.  So it's very  fast to respond
here.  That's actually because
it's  through Firebase static
hosting, so it's behind the
global CDM.  And to prove that I
can actually look at  the
source code, and there you can
actually see all of  those
responses.
So before in Firebase hosting,
you couldn't have  these dynamic
type responses.  And this is a
node  application. through
express.
So here, I'm actually
using
a JS application.  And  then
I'm exporting app as this.
And if I go to my  Firebase
configuration,
I'm actually rewriting the
entire site to go to that cloud
function.  So star, star  goes
to that cloud function.
All right.
Well, before, we had Cloud
Functions  for Firebase,
Firebase developers in order to
get any of  this functionality
would have to spin up their own
servers.  That's a lot of cost
you would have to, you  know,
have DevOps, you would have to
worry -- you would  have to
worry about down network or slow
network  connections, whereas
the Firebase STKs take care of
all  of this for you.  As a
result, you would have a lot, a
lot of complexity.  Now with
Cloud Functions for  Firebase,
this is no longer the case.  You
can actually  spin up robust
Node.js code to listen to
rights on the  database.  You
can use the pub/sub to listen to
any  workers you have, and we
have the HTTPS that takes in
full express application.  And
they can pull in any of  the
power libraries available to you
on NPM.  So I hope  I was able
to convince you that with Cloud
Functions  with Firebase, you
can do all of the things, and
you  don't need a server.
[Applause]
Thank you.
>> How is everybody doing?
>> Hello.
>> All right. All right. Yeah,
we made it work.   I'm David, I
am a partner at a New York City
-based  digital agency.  We work
with large brands, large
companies to launch mobile apps.
>> Hi, everyone,
my name is Seth Ladd,, and I
work  at Google.
>> We work with the latest
technologies to launch  a app in
the United States in record
time.
>> So as an agency, we always
face tight deadlines deadlines.
Our clients are pushing us to
do more,  faster, and cheaper.
So we're always looking for
across  platform technologies,
special architectures like
service architectures like
you've been seeing a lot of
today to help us do things
quicker.  Our clients want us
to deliver value, not lines of
code or overhead.  They  don't
want want us to reinvent the
wheel.  So we've been  looking
at these technologies, but we
always had a bit  of skepticism,
a little bit of lack of
competence.   Until recently,
when we started working with
Flutter and  Firebase.
>> And we're very glad you found
Flutter.  At  Flutter, we help
teams build quality apps faster
and  easier.  That's what we're
all about.  In fact, at  Google
for a while now, we've been
helping teams build  successful
and business-critical apps.  So
then the  question we asked
ourselves is could we replicate
the  success of Flutter outside
of Google?
>> So to help us answer that, we
started working  with the
Google developer agency program,
which is how  we met David and
Posse.  We thought Flutter was a
great  fit for agencies and any
team that wanted to move fast
without sacrificing quality and
needing to reach all  users
across all of mobile.
>> When we dug into Flutter, we
finally thought we  found a
platform that we could use
across iOS and  Android that
built apps that were in
distinguishable from  coding
apps.  A strongly-typed language
, which is very  Devonte to our
developer, and a hot reload
feature that  once we started
using it drastically increased
our  developers.  We were ready
to dive into this technology.
But as an agency, we need a
client as excited about it  as
we were.  Then it happened.
Hamilton, the hit  Broadway
musical in New York City called
us up to do an  app.  And when
we told them about Firebase and
Flutter,  they were as excited
about this as we were.  Now, for
this of you who don't know,
Hamilton the musical is a  huge
deal in the U.S.  They have a
very large and very  passionate
fan base.  The musical is
constantly sold out out.  It's
nearly impossible to get tickets
to across  the U.S.  It has won
11 Grammys, an Emmy, and more.
>> When the Hamilton team came
to us, all they  cared about was
creating great experiences for
their  fans.  They wanted to
give their fans as much as they
could.  And they had no
internal tech team.  So the idea
of maintaining two separate
code bases for iOS or  Android
or a Fleet of servers even on
Google Cloud or  something easy
like cloud infrastructure was
daunting to  them.  This is a
lot of technology for basically
a bunch  of theater people who
have no technology in experience
.   So the promise of cross
platform frameworks and
serverless architectures was
really interesting.  And  most
importantly, they had an
incrediblely-tight deadline.
For all the features they had to
do, they only had three  months
, and this deadline could not be
moved.  So at  that point the
Flutter team was very excited
and  honestly a little nervous.
Remember, at that time, it  was
still early for Flutter.  It
hadn't yet been used  for such a
prominent five star consumer
app.  The  Hamilton team had
a long list of really
important  features and im
movable deadline, so could it
work?
>> And as if that pressure
wasn't high enough, we  got a
phone call from the COO of
Hamilton and said  Hamilton is
really big.  Fans love it.
We've never  failed at anything
and this app will not be the
first  time.
>> So this is exactly the kind
of challenge our  team was
looking for so of course we said
, yes, let's do  it.  The posse
team, Hamilton team, and Flutter
would  build a plan to execute.
Posse would build an app to
the specification requirements
of Hamilton.  And to fix  all
the requirements and use cases
for the app.
>> To give you an idea of what's
in this app and  how
complicated it was, there's a
whole lot of features  in here.
And, again, three short months.
And so  there's a lottery that
tickets are really hard to get.
You have to buy them a year
out and aftermarket they're,
like, $1,000 a piece.  So they
have this lottery that  you can
enter to win $10 tickets.  Tens
of thousands of  people go for
these every day.  And also a
place to buy  Hamilton
merchandise.  And you need
Stripe integration  to process
payment all done on cloud based
functions.   And we have this
Newham cam feature with overlays
at the  theaters and other
places.  A ton of features.  And
that's just the tip of the
iceberg.  And, again, we had
almost no time to do this.  So
being able to do this  really
quickly and really effectively
and beautifully  via custom
branded design was absolutely
essential.  But  the legal
question for this was could we
build an app  with Flutter and
with Firebase on this timeline
with all
of these features in a way
that the fans would love it  and
they would feel that it was in
distinguishable from a  native
app?
>> And, yes, the fans loved it.
The media loved  it.  And both
the Appstore and the play store
both  featured the app.
>> And its uptake surprised even
the Hamilton team team.  Since
we've launched, we've had almost
a million  installs, nearly
half a million active users,
already  taken two million lot
tery entries, and we are already
one of the fastest growing
apps on the Google Cloud
Platform.  Flutter and Firebase,
these aren't just toys.   These
are real things that work in
production at  tremendously high
scale.
>> So Flutter and Firebase are a
huge reason that  we got this
app to so many fans quickly.
The speed of  development and
the features that are given to
us by  these tools really
couldn't be matched for our
timeline.   So what we want to
do now is we want to share some
patterns and code to show you
that you too can use these
tools, that you can accelerate
your process and benefit  from
them just like we did.  And
we're going to start  first with
Firebase.  So Firebase offers a
ton of tools.   You may have
been to some talks already today
where  they're talking about
all the ways that you can use
Firebase.  The really fun thing
about Firebase is you  can use
as many of these things or as
few of these  things as you want
.  If you just want to use
Google  Analytics, no problem.
Just add SDK, events, you have
analytics.  This is new to us.
We only use Firebase.   The
authentication product was one
that saved us a  tremendous
amount of time.  You add the SDK
, your  authentication strategy
is prebaked for you, pretty
much much.  E-mail, phone number
, Google log in, anything you
want to do, it's there.  Google
Cloud storage or public  let's
see the
pub/sub pub/sub, it's almost
trivial.  And then there's the
realtime data.  It's a different
type of database than  probably
a lot of you are used to.  But
it's realtime.   And that's
something that our team hadn't
really  experienced before.  We
were used to apps where you make
a request, you get a response.
The realtime database,  once
you add the Firebase SDK, it's
right there.  Your  data is live
.  We're really proud of the
fact that our  application does
not have a single port of re
fresh  anywhere in the app.
What you see is what you get
live  in realtime.  But for us,
the real start story is Cloud
Functions, which is relatively
new.  Before this, you  know, we
used Firebase for other pieces,
but not really  as a full,
complete server.  Cloud
Functions gives us  the tools we
need for this to be a
first-class back-end.
We used it to integrate with
Stripe API and all kinds of
third party services.  We use it
to fan out our data.   We use
it as an API.
So we have all of these tools,
realtime database,  Cloud
Functions, and one of the things
that when we were  getting
started is we had to figure out
how to make an  API out of these
tools.  We're used to building
out  express or Rails servers
where the app makes a request
for your response.  You probably
all build APIs like  that
before for your apps.  We were
struggling with how  do we do
this, you know,?  We didn't want
to build a Web  server because
what's the point of a serverless
architecture if you're making
servers?  And then it hit  us.
We had this connection already
do our realtime  database the
ability to read and write data
at  incrediblely fast speeds.
And we have Cloud Functions.
So we divide this asynchronous
approach where we use the
database as a connectiveity
connectiveity mechanism to do
the same work  that we would
typically do with a Web search.
So, for  example, let's say the
app wants to do something.  For
instance, enter the lottery.
What we do is we drop
a  request, write a request to
the Firebase realtime  database
, we trigger a cloud function
based on that, the  cloud
function does what we need to do
.  Checks the user user, does
the work that we don't want the
client to do.   We want it to be
controlled and protected on our
server.   When it's done, it
writes a response back to the
realtime database.  The database
-- or the app is  listening to
this node on the database.  And
since it's  realtime, as soon as
we make that response, the app
gets  it, this is if your Web
API responded with some JSON,
and there we have it.  We have
an API.  It was  incrediblely
powerful for us.  Once we saw
this pattern,  not only was it
high performance, it saved us a
ton of  time.  This app has zero
networking.  We had zero HTTPS
Web APIs at all.  Everything is
done through the  database.  So
this was, like, mind-blowing to
us and  saved us a tremendous
amount of time.  So to show you
that this is real and to show
you how easy it is to  build an
API
using the realtime database
and Cloud  Functions, we're
going to demo this pattern.
This  pattern is basically the
same exact pattern we're using
in this app that tens of
thousands and upwards, we're
getting into the hundreds of
thousands of users are  using
every single day.
Can we go to the slides, please,
?  Or the code.   Sorry.  The
first thing I wanted to show you
was the  package of JSON.  The
reason I wanted to show you this
was because on our team, we're
always looking to  eliminate as
many dependencies as we can.
We really  only need two to get
this started.  We need the
Firebase  admin module to talk
to the database, pretty much to
read and write to Firebase from
our server, and we need  our
Firebase functions library to
register functions and  define
our triggers.  You may notice
that we are  actually doing dev
dependencies, we're using
TypeScript  that you'll see in
Web pack.  This is one that
really  improved our efficiency
during the process.  So how do
we create a function?  It's
incrediblely easy.  In this
case it's JavaScript -- well,
TypeScript.  You would  write it
like any other JavaScript
function.  Again,  there's no
node here, no express, no middle
wear, body  parsers, nothing
like that.  All we do is we
define a  trigger path, how
we want our function to be
invoked.   In this particular
case, since we're doing our
request  response API, we want
to on create when someone adds
new  data to our database, at a
particular path that we've
defined, in this case requests
lottery entry, user ID  push key
.  When new data is written to
that path, it's  going to wake
up our function and do the work
that we  need it to do.  So
we've defined this interlotry
function.
So the key thing here is why are
we doing this why  do we care?
Historically, you might put a
lot of this  work on the client
side or Firebase gives you
direct  read, write access into
your app into Firebase.  But we
don't want people just to drop
a lottery entry into the
database.  That's something that
can be abused.  So we.   The
this to be protected behind the
API.  When the event  fires, and
it's triggered, it passes this
event into our  function.  Event
has a bunch of data that we can
access  from that event.  So
this is where we can get from
our  database path, you can get
the user ID, we can get the
actual data that the app passes
to us in the request  that stays
in the database.
So it behaves kind of like a Web
API, but it's  just a database.
The next thing we do is we do
some  sensitive business logic.
These are stubbed out for the
purposes of the demo.  But maybe
we want to check if the  user's
eligible or make sure the
lottery's still open or  do
something that's private that we
don't want the world  to know
about.  We can do all of those
here.  Just  normal JavaScript.
They can be calls to third
party  APIs, they can be
asynchronous things, whatever we
want  to do.  But assuming
everything's okay, we define our
entry data object, and then we
can save it out to the
database.  Now, this particular
area of the database,  like, our
lottery entries right here,
this is something  that is
protected by database rules.
Nobody can read or  write to
this.  Rewrite false.  This is
really important  because we
only want our systems to be able
to allow  people to create a
lottery entry.  By doing it in
this  pattern, we can make sure
that our API's safe.  Once
we're
done with that, the user has
successfully saved  their
lottery entry, now we just need
to write the  response back to
our response node in the
database.  A  helper function
here called respond, we'll maybe
post  some of this code
afterwards.  But this just
basically  writes our response
object with data, chance ID
generated through this and maybe
a message.  We write  that back
to the response node.  And
since the app after  it made the
request has an active listener
on the  response, as soon as we
make that write, the app gets
the update and the spinner stops
spinning and the app is  done.
But there's a key point we want
to make.  Unlike  a normal Web
request where the connection is
open, and  you close that
connection, and it's hanging out
there,  and you're waiting for
the response to finish, this is
asynchronous.  Once we make
that request, the database,  the
cloud function's running in the
background, it's  almost
totally detached from the end.
So even though we  respond here
and say, hey, you're done.
Congrats.  We  can keep going.
Our cloud function doesn't have
to stop  there.  We can maybe
fan out the data to other areas
of  the database or send a push
notification or something  else.
When we're finally done, you
just return and tell  our
function we're done.
So it's really cool.  Again, it
saved us a  tremendous amount of
time.  Can we go back to the
slides slides?
And there's a few key points I
wanted to  highlight here.
This is -- we call this
asynchronous  database-driven
API.  No network code at all.
In our  team, we always spend
more time than we expect writing
code to interface with some
sort of Web server.   Networking
code that we don't like writing
that we have  to where he re:
write all the time that our
clients  don't care about.  No
network.  It was all handled by
the Firebase SDK the second we
were able to interact  with our
database.  The other thing is
there's no  authentication or
error handleing.  Again, all
baked into  the Firebase SDK.
It's incrediblely-high scale as
well.   Firebase scales really
nicely, and it has this amazing
realtime performance that we
were worried about how is  this
going to work performance-wise?
But because it's  such a
blazing-fast database, the
performance has been  really
amazing.  And
perhaps most importantly for
our  client and for us, no
servers to maintain.  We didn't
have to worry about the type of
Web server we're using,  who's
going to patch the libraries and
all the operating  systems that
our servers are running and how
are we  going to handle the
scale and how are we going to
auto  scale whenever lottery
opens?  Cloud Functions and
Firebase just did it all for us.
So Firebase really  worked for
us.  It was a tremendous win
for the project,  but it was
only half the story.  We also
had to craft  the beautiful,
custom design for Hamilton to
really  showcase their brand in
an app.  And for that, we turn
to Flutter, and I'm going to
turn it over to
Seth now.
>> Thanks, Dave. As we heard in
the beginning,  Flutter is a
mobile app SDK that makes it
easier to  deliver high-quality
apps.  At its technical core,
Flutter is a portable renderer
and toolkit.  Now, all of  these
layers you see here are
compiled to native arm  code for
fast startup and predictable
performance.
But even more importantly, this
portable renderer  is shipped
inside of your app when you
deploy your app  via IPAs, the
renderer toolkit and your code
are all  bundled together and
shipped out.  This means that
the  beautiful pixels that your
designers work so hard on and
the beautiful UI that your
developers built is the same
beautiful experience your users
will get, no matter what  OEM
version or OS version they
happen to be running.   Now, of
course, I could keep telling you
about it, but  it's much cooler
to show you about Flutter.  So
let's go  to the demo set up
here.
Okay.  We're going to show three
important parts  of Flutter,
which
David took advantage of when
they  built the app.  The first
is the reactive widget library
library, the second is hot re
load, and the third is  Flutter
Fire.  Let's start by the
lottery screens here on  the
phone.  This is an iOS phone and
a Android phone.   You can see
that it's a beautiful brand
first design,  and the colors
look similar down here.  So it
could  deliver a consistent UI
experience across all the users
across all of mobile.  But just
because these look  identical
doesn't mean that they have to
act identical.   Flutter and
posse know that users on iOS has
a  particularly muffle memory
when they scroll and a
particular scrolling friction on
Android that they are  used to.
So let's look at that on
Android, you can see  the over
scroll glow.  And on iOS, you
get the bounce.   So the
Hamilton app is beautiful and a
consistent brand  experience and
still feels very natural to
users on both  platforms.
Okay.  So let's pick a piece of
this UI and show  you how we
built this.  We're going to pick
the little  blue badge here,
the active badge here to play
with and  show you how it works.
So let's go to the code here.
This is the code for that
active badge.  And the first
thing that I want you to notice
is that it's all code.   There's
no markup, there's no XML, no
other language  that you have to
learn or build tools for.  It's
a  single language with a
single set of libraries for you
to build your UI, manipulate
your UI, and build your
business logic.  This means that
you get the power of  code and
the power of IDEs like
refactoring, et cetera,  when
you build all aspects of that
front-end.  The other  thing I
want you to see is that this
lottery state badge badge, this
active blue box right here is
itself a  widget.  Widgets in
Flutter are the core, basic
building  blocks of all UI.  In
fact, widgets themselves are
made  out of more widgets.  This
composition model, this
composition
architecture is very powerful.
You can re recompose the core
widgets that we ship in our
toolkit,  things like padding
and text to more beautiful,
higher  level widgets which
themselves can be composed.
It's a  really good model.  Now
let's look at what it's like to
actually code this UI.  Let's
say that we did some user
studies and this blue here made
may be not working.  So we  sit
next to our designer and we say
what are the colors  you've got?
Well, of course we have all
the colors.   But we have code
completion, so you can see what
the  options there are, so let's
say we want to try green.   So
I'm going to jump over to the
console that's driving  these
two apps.  As it's initializeing
the system here,.   Okay.
Great.  It has changed live, hot
reloaded to  change from blue
to green.  Thank you.
[Applause]
This hot reload system really
enabled posse and  others to
iterate very quickly in their
development  cycle.  But we can
do more than change colors.
Let's  change math here.  Let's
say we want to change the size
of this button here live.  So
we're going to go over and  re
load here and, oh, no.  So what
just happened?  Well,  most of
the UI rendered just fine.  But
the widget here,  this active
widget had a syntax error and
luckily, the  framework said I
can render everything except
that one  widget that you had,
and I'm going to show you what
that  error is, and it even
tells me what the syntax error
is  here in the red little box.
Sure enough, it's a syntax
that forgot to finish.  Let's go
here, type R, and the  time it
takes me to look back here, we
have not only  recovered from a
syntax error, live without re
starting  the app, but it's much
bigger to see.
There's one more aspect I want
to show.  Let's tap  on this
button a couple of times and add
some state to  our app.
Hopefully, you can see I've
tapped each button  seven times.
State your app is a user
logged in or do I  have any
items in the cart?  In this case
, how many  times have I tapped
the button?  So we're going to
make  another change here.
Let's go to save, active, R for
re reload and boom right there.
Not only do you get that  about
a second hot reload experience,
but the state of  my app
remained live.  So it's a state
ful hot reload.   This is really
powerful when you want to work
in that  one esoteric screen
seven levels down in your app
after  you've logged in, et
cetera, et cetera, you're all
the  way in your app, and you
don't have to restart that flow
every time you want to make
these changes.  Stateful hot  re
load.
Now, the next thing I want to
show you is right  now, we're
just adding numbers here when I
tap the  button.  But let's make
it real.  Let's make it connect
to Firebase in the cool Cloud
Functions that David  showed us
earlier.  So Flutter has an
awesome package  manager where
you could just declare your
dependencies,  get your plugins,
get your third-party libraries
and of  course Firebase through
the Flutter fire package is a
first class citizen here in the
ecosystem.  So it's very  easy
to declare.  Now let's go over
to the code that  handles this
button press and instead of just
incrementing a counter, we're
going to enter the lottery
lottery.  And let's look at the
code for entering the  lottery.
There's two things I want to
point out.  One  is these calls
to set state.  This is a
framework feature  of Flutter
where you can easily identify
where the state  of your
application is changing.  It
makes it very easy  to look
around your code and say this is
where you  update the state
or domain model.  Second, it
tells the  framework rebuild
your UI.  So this is that
reactive  part of the Flutter
framework that we're talking
about.   The second thing I want
to show is post action.  A very
cool function that David and
his team wrote to  encapsulate
that Async request for response
pattern that  we saw earlier for
Cloud Functions, et cetera,.
Let's jump in here real quick.
I want to show  normal Firebase
code.  If you're used to
Firebase, these  APIs are going
to feel very familiar.  It's all
brought  up into Flutter for
you to access.
So we've made a significant
change to our  application here.
We've added a huge business
logic and  code to our app.  Now
let's do final hot reload.  In
about sun second again, our app
is updated.  And when I  tap
this button, we're now really
talking to realtime  database,
which really listens for Cloud
Functions and  really awaits for
a response all hot reloaded and
live  for you.  Come on, iOS.
Yes.  Okay.  Okay.  So there's
obviously a lot more cool
features to Flutter in  Firebase
, but hopefully you've got a
sense about how  fast, fun, and
easy it is to build UIs and
connect it to  Firebase.  So the
question is if we can go back
to the  slides is how did this
actually work for David and his
team?
>> So Flutter was really, really
important.  Again Again, we had
a really tight timeline, and we
had a  client with high demands
, both in terms of of the
features and the experience we
wanted to deliver.  And  we
wanted to deliver this beautiful
brand experience  across both
platforms.  IOS and Android.
And we didn't  have time to make
sure every little pixel was
perfect on  both platforms.  So
Flutter really helped us there.
Coding once, seeing the
designs, but yet still feeling
very natural and feeling very
native.  The other thing  is
that it allowed us to move
really fast in experiment.   Our
designers were constantly, you
know, tweaking things things,
the client always had new input
or once they  would get a build,
they want want to change
something.   So the ability to
move fast and use tools like hot
re reload to modify that design
in realtime saved us a ton  of
time.
Also, in the long run, this
Flutter provides an  amazing
ability to reduce our
maintenance cost and also
decrease the cost of adding new
features because every  single
time we need to fix a bug or
change a design or  add a new
feature, we just have to do it
one place.  And  our developers
say laying out UI with Flutter,
significantly faster than on
iOS or Android.  And the  hot re
load, you know, if you are all
mobile developers  here or if
any of you are, waiting for your
application  to recompile and
navigate down to where you need
to go,  this is real money.
This is realtime.  Our clients
are  paying for us to redevelop
these apps.  So our  developers
are not waiting for Xcode to re
develop the  application, that's
more time we're waiting on
features.   And also because of
things like Flutter fire and
Flutter Flutter's plugin system
and using tools like Firebase is
and all of the great resources
we have at our disposal,  we
spent less time building
plumbing, you know,  technical
overhead
in order to make this app work
and  more time working on
features.
So I'm wondering, has anyone
here faced incrediblely
incredibly-tough deadline in the
work that you do?  Have  you
ever felt pressure from, you
know, your bosses or  your
senior leaders to ship more
features faster?  Have  you ever
had a design team that wants to
iterate a  design quicker.  Hey
, I have a new design.  Can I
see it  on screen?  Or perhaps
you have stakeholders in your
business that don't want to hear
it about your cool
infrastructure solution or about
the code you've written  to
optimize this, that, or the
other thing.  They just  want to
see new features, you know,?
What have you done  for me
lately?  What kind of value are
you adding to our  business
application?
So Flutter and Firebase for us
was a tremendous  toolkit to
deliver on those needs, you know
,?  Tough  timeline.  Branded
design, beautiful experience,
complicated features, protected
operations and logic in  the
back-end.  And it's really easy
to get started.   That's right
it's less than a minute to
create a fire- fire-base project
and Flutter is object source.
You  just get clone our repo and
even command Flutter create  to
Bootstrap your first project.
We encourage you to  visit our
office hours up on the third
floor, and we  have instructor-
led training for both Firebase
and  Flutter today and tomorrow.
>> And we hope that our talk
today inspires you  all.  That
these aren't just cool
technologies.  Real  businesses
at real scale are using these
out there today  to go run
production code.  So we hope
that you can  embrace some of
the learning you had here today
and try  something amazing.
Thank you very much.
[Applause]
>> Hello, Krakow. Give us a
wave.  We have got a  lot, a lot
of content for you.  So on
stage we have five  speakers
that are going to be talking
about a variety of  topics.  So
I will start with some of the
things that  may not know about
or some of the top tips.  That
we, we  can have Marc give us an
update.  And then we have
Santiago, who's going to give us
an update on ExoPplayer,  and
then we have Aga, and
last but definitely not least,
we have Dan who is going to
talk about
audio.  So get  your hashtag
ready.  My clock already started
.  Let's  get going.  What I'm
going to do is talk about three
things.  And quite often, it's
not immediately obvious  when
you
-- the first thing is if your
app is slow,  please, please
tell us.  The only way to watch
the  connect to the Internet by
the phone is through  Bluetooth.
We have consequently added
both Wi-Fi and  cellular to the
watch.  With 2.0, we have added
a new  way for you to connect,
which is direct HTTP connection.
What this
means is if you have
connection code base on  your
mobile, you can just reuse
exactly the same code on  your
watch.  So that's what's been
launched.  The  advantage of
that is, of course, it can run
your app,  even if they're
paired in the iPhone.  Because
it is  no additional component
required on the phone.  Another
advantage is that users can now
directly install your  app on
the watch itself.  We have play
store on the  watch so that the
user can download whatever they
want  onto their most personal
ized device.  And in order for
you to tell us that your app
support this directly, all  you
need to do is put on this
metadata check in your
Android ware app.  And after
of that that, we will put  it on
the play store on your watch.
And it will be both  accessible
to those users on a Android
phone as well as  an iPhone.
Next, standalone architecture.
So many of you  have heard about
model view controller, so
that's pretty  much done; right?
Your display logic on the
device.   Done.  Lightning talk.
In reality, it's not quite
that.   So today, the center of
gravity for the user is a lot of
our mobile.  You have heard
about mobile first.  And  quite
often, we forgot about all the
other factors that  a user
already have.  And it doesn't
even need to be a  factor.  It
can just be the same user with
another phone phone.  And this
particular platform is
particularly  easy to go into if
you have a user credential that
is  telephone-based.  Meaning
that when a user log into one
device, you lock them out of
another.  And I see this
assumption being built into app
again and again.  And  when they
come to expand their apps, this
really, really  hit them.
Because the user can only log
into one device  at any one time
.  So at the very, very minimum,
I would  strongly encourage you
even if you just started
Bootstrapping
or you're working on a project
over the  weekend, build the
assumption that a user will have
more  than one device.  So
allow multiple security tokens
to  be active at one point.  You
don't need to build cloud-
cloud-based messaging
synchronization.  None of that
ever start.  Maybe when you get
your funding, you could  do that
.
The next thing that we realize
when we start  building 2.0,
which support log in is that a
lot of the  time the user or the
first time the user access your
app  could be device.  Which
means they may not have an
account to sign in.  So if you
assume the user just has  the
sign in button on the app, you
may be missing a  whole chunk of
users.  So what we would
encourage you to  do as you
build experiences, also put in a
register  button so that you
can enable users that's coming
in by  other form factors, be it
Android wear, Android TV to
actually register for your
service the very first time
that they're logging in.
Last but not least, Android wear
for China.  So we  are in China
, and it is extremely popular.
It is our  second largest market
around the world behind behind
the U.S.   And as you know, many
of Google services are not
available in China.  And so one
of the thing that you  should do
Google Play services on Android
wear is that  to check it is
available.  So there's two ways
to this  this.  One is when
you're connecting
to the Google Play  services,
check if the API is available.
And second if  you have, say,
five of them and three of them
connect,  and you still want
them to work, then you could do
this  and say, you know, add API
available.  And then check
that the API is actually
available for your user.
And there are three types of
services that's  available in
China in a Google Play services
package.   The first one is
Google Fit.  You can get the
seven-day  count from that.
Second is fused location
provider.  I  really, really
recommend that you use it.  It
has a lot  of battery
optimization built in, as well
as all the  different
combinations of way of getting
location.  Last  but not least,
we have the wear data layer.  So
a layer,  you would need Google
Play services.  And if you want
to  compile just one against
the Google Play services just
once, then you should.  Compile
with the version 10.2.0.   And
what they've enabled you to do
is for your app to  run both in
China and also outside of China.
So with  that, I will hand it
over to Marc who will be talking
about Android TV.  Thank you.
[Applause]
>> Thank you. Yeah. Let's talk
about Android TV.   You may
have already seen the keynote
where we announced  cool
features for Android TV coming
soon.  I'm going to  talk about
two of them, one is the Google
Assistant on  Android TV and the
other is the new home screen
starting  with Android.  Google
Assistant goes Android TV,
that's  not surprising.  We want
to have it on every platform
available, so TV is the next
logical step.  What do you  need
to do as a developer to make
your app integrated  with Google
Assistant?  There are basically
two ways  Google Assistant
interacts with your app.  First,
it  needs to find your app
provides.  So it
is done by using  a search
adviser.  And second, once the
company is found found, it needs
a way to play, it needs a way
to remote  control your app for
play back.  For this, it uses
the  media session API.  Both
are kind of well-known
acknowledges.  We have on
Android TV since the very  first
lounge a few years ago.  What
you see here is that
all universal or global
search is exactly feature on the
former Android TV versions,
which uses search provider  as
well as the assistant does.
Google Assistant now re reuses
the service and provides a new,
more modern- modern-looking user
interface like you see here,
the  presentation of the results
.  Now users can choose from
these movies and start play back
.  These are well-known
technologies, there is a lot of
documentation available  on
developer Android.com.  There is
a tech guide making  TV apps
searchable and also a lean back
sample code that  you can use
and adapt for your app.  So now,
assistant  now found the
content or the user found the
content he  wants to watch and
now assistant uses the media
session  API to start play back.
We see here
this call back you  and your
app just need to delegate these
calls in this  case, and it's in
a exoplayer.
Media session as well is
documented with the media
session and there is also media
session extension for  exoplayer
, which provides out of the box
integration  with the media
session.
So now let's have a new lack
at  the home screen of Android.
You see this layout, the  arrow
with favorite apps.  But then
you see channel rows rows.
Programs which an app wants to
advertise to users  for
recommendation.  Each app can at
least place one on  the home
screen and the application takes
the data and  placed this row
from a database, from a company
provider provider.  So your app
needs to insert data into
exactly  this content provider.
Let's have a look how this
looks  in code.  We have here a
sample, which adds to the
content provider.  At the very
start, we just create a  builder
, a builder instance in this
case a channel  builder instance
, which then populates with what
we want  to use for our channel
.
In the next step, we use now the
build content  values and
insert these values into our
content provider  by the TV
contract we are using.  And the
next step now  we want to add a
logo to our channel.  So the
user can  easily recognize to
which app a channel belongs and
uses  the channel logo method
here, the channel ID, and the
logo.
And now finally, we want to make
this channel  visible on the
home screen for this requested
to make it  browseable, with the
request channel browseable
method.
Now we have such a channel
visible on the home  screen and
of course we want to add
programs.  This  works in the
very same way, only in a very
similar way.   Again, it creates
a builder instance and this
time it's  a preview program
builder instance and repopulate
the  data in this builder.  Most
importantly, the channel ID,
of course, with which we link
our program to a given  channel
we already create.  Once we add
a type to the  description, we
can now take the content values
again  built by our builder, and
insert it into the content
provider of the TV contract.
This API is already documented.
More detail on
developer.Android.comAndroid
.com, it provides you more
details with  how you can
manipulate your channel and
program data in  the database.
With this last point to our
sandbox where  you can play
around with the new launch
screen and also  the Android TV
office hours, we're happy to
answer your  questions about
Android TV.  With this, I give
it over  to Santiago.  Thank you
very much.
[Applause]
>> Hello. Let's talk about
ExoPlayer.  ExoPlayer  is an
application level media library
for Android.  It's  an
alternative to Android's
platform media player, and  it
has four main goals.  The first
goal is to reduce the  effects
of fragmentation.  It has been
one of the most  affected areas
by fragmentation.  And ExoPlayer
moves a  majority of the media
player implementation to the
application layer, so it's
possible to update through
regular application updates,
hence reducing the effects  of
fragmentation.  Most works
jellybean, onwards.  That
covers a vast majority of
devices.
Our second goal and the least is
to provide  advanced features.
So you already possibly know
that  ExoPlayer supports some
features, not currently
supported by the API.  This
includes dash, streaming,
caching.  There are others.  But
we are constantly  working to
add new features.  So our latest
include a  set of tools for
downloading almost any kind of
media.   There's also dynamic
play lists, so you can create
dynamic play lists, modify them
on the fly, the  functionality
is also built in the player.  So
if we  know with enough
anticipation what media's coming
, we  can shorten by a lot the
gap between items in the play
list.  And even though very cool
stuff with this, like,  for
example, brings me to my next
picture, which is --  there's
this new component called audio
processors,  which includes
features like the feedback
adjustment all  the way back
from jellybean onwards and
virtual reality.   And finally,
a slightly more technical level,
there is  support for the full
now.  So
we have had support for a
long time now.  And now we have
it for the remaining  skin types
.  Most interestingly
include this skin type  for HLS
.  So this is interesting for
content providers.   This is in
by no means a list.
So there are tons of use cases
for ExoPlayer.  We  know, in
fact, no size fits all, so the
ability to  customize is one of
the core principles in ExoPlayer
.
So this is our third goal to
allow customization.   So, say,
for example, if you have amazing
content that  you want to
stream to devices, and you come
out with a  custom ERM screen,
so you create a component, and
you  check the player.  And then
after shipping and having  some
metrics, you realize you also
want to tweak away,  you mess
your band with because the
network conditions  conditions
-- and, by the way, it's also
good to custom customize the
mechanisms.  So you create
components for  that, you check
on ExoPlayer, new metrics you
realize  that you would also
customize -- you would also like
to  customize a way for the
media.  So you also -- all of
these things you can inject into
ExoPlayer.  There are  tons of
hot spots for injecting custom
components in  ExoPlayer.  Very
different for levels.  And now
I'm  going to speak about our
fourth bowl, which is enable
integration with enabled
libraries.  Extensions are
models with external
dependencies.  For example, the
IMA  extension.
For media distributors who want
to monetize  their media, this
extension, which is a wrapper
around  the Google interactive
media SDK makes it extremely
easy  to play ads on your
content.  And as a play list,
it's  integrated into the player
, so you can reduce and almost
eliminate the way it cost by
buffering mid-rows during  media
play back.
There's Alice the Cast extension
, which is quite  now.  Users
effortlessly cast their content
into cast castable devices, and
you can use your custom UI
components, if any, you are
using to control ExoPlayer  to
control play back on cast-
compatible devices.   Chromecast
and TV is not all we have in
mind.  There's  also the media
extension, which allows
ExoPlayer to  publish media
session, therefore, you can
control that  play back session
from other apps in other devices
.  And  the images that's being
used on mobile device and
Android out.  So this is very
interesting.
So ExoPlayer can also be used,
maybe you know, in  virtual
reality environments.  But the G
VR extension  also allows for
audio player.  Also, thanks to
audio  process that I mentioned
before.  There are many other
extensions.  Due to time
constraints, I'm not going to
delve into them.  But I just
want to mention that most  of
them or many of them can be used
to bundle your own  encoders.
So you can make sure there's
specific code  you're looking
for on all the devices.
So that's -- for me, at least
check the medium box box,
I hope to see you tomorrow at
the office hours.   Thank you
very much.
[Applause]
>> Thank you. Today, I want to
spend a little  time talking
about one of the APIs that we
run with  Android Wear, and it
has to do with round screens.
So  this is our new launcher
that I started working on about
a year and a half ago.  And
what we wanted to do with  this
launcher is we wanted it to be
fast, we wanted it  to be used.
But most importantly, we wanted
it to fit  in with a curved
screen that all the new watches
have.   So round watches are the
most popular watches at the
moment.  Users love them, and
they are much, much, much  more
popular than the square ones, so
we wanted to  adjust our design
to that new trend and make it
visually  more appealing and
more fitting with the round UI.
So this is how we wanted it to
look.  We needed to  figure out
how to implement it.  So this
is what I got  from my designers
.  Here on the right-hand side,
which  generally when you first
look at it, looks fabulous.
However, how it really feels
like is something like this
this; right?  And that is
because a lot of people forget
that the launcher is static.
I'm not quite sure they  forget
but the launcher is not static.
You can scroll  it up and down.
And once you scroll it up and
down, you  need to be able to
animate those elements into the
launcher alongside the curve.
And you don't only want  to
animate them just like the yarn,
you want to scale  them.  So
you can see the ones here at the
top are  slightly smaller than
the ones in the center, which
are  the ones we want to focus
on.
So for regular lists, a lot of
the work done by  Android
framework.  But nobody exactly
thought about  round screens.
So this was a new challenge for
us.  So  when I started looking
at the code, you can see on this
left-hand side here how how
the straight works.  It's kind
of straight.
[Laughter]
And when you scroll it, every
single element in  the list
moves by the same amount of
pixels at the same  time, which
creates an illusion of scrolling
.  It really  is super simple of
function.  Now, this is not the
case,  obviously, with the
curved list that we have here.
So  you can see that not only do
we want to keep on the Yics Y
Y-axis.  We also for the curve
want them with the X-axis
X-axis.  I'm okay with math, so
I figured a function for  this.
You can translate X to Y by
using a very simple  circle base
function.  So I went back to my
design team,  I built a
prototype and said, hey, guys,
it's working  fine.  It's well.
And I said this is really not
good.  This is  terrible.  We
can't launch this.  There's no
way.  It's  so bad.  It's so
horrible.  No way.  What we
really want  is this.  We want
the circles to be equidistant
from  each other, how you see
here.  Which
means you can't  linearly have
the Y position exactly like you
would have  in the stateless.
You not only need to translate
in the  X directions, you also
need to do it in the Y
directions directions.  You can
see there's a slight slope of
the  lines here and here.  Also,
the slope goes up here but  on
the flip side here, on the
bottom, it goes down.  So  it
doesn't make it easier at all.
So instead of changing just the
value of X, we  needed to change
both the values of X and Y.  So
this is  a problem in Android
because once you've changed the
X  or Y values, that triggers a
new layout path each time.   So
if you're changing Y in a
vertically-scrolling list,  you
will trigger a layout path on
and on and on and on  because
the old values -- sorry, the new
values treat it  as an old
value.  And this is obviously
not what we  wanted or.  So
instead of changing the value of
Y, we  decided to translate the
view by just a little bit.  So
that is a little difference
translation did not trigger  a
layout path.
So this was a simple solution,
and to implement in  the launch
er.  But as you can see, this is
probably not  a unique problem.
So we cover that, actually, it
works  for us for the curve.
But it could work for any other
path.  So that's why on the top
of the solution for the  launch
er, my team built an an API that
enables you to use  any chosen
path, however funky it may be.
If you want  to implement it,
you can.  I don't know why, but
you can can.  The only caveat is
we will not give you the math.
I've had enough of math.  So
we will give you a  container, a
wearable recycleer view, but
you need to  supply us with the
path.  And then how the path is
used  is a little bit like this:
So this will go live when it
drops to open source,  this is
the curve that we use for the
launcher.  I won't  bore you
with details, basically some
extend there.   This is the kind
of map
that you might want to -- and
then when you have the map for
the path, this is how you  would
actually use it in code.  This
line here is the  crucial one.
Where you just get the tangent
line for  the path you have and
then apply the position to the
children in the view.
So here, again, this is the
general architecture  of the API
, this is all provided in the
where UI support  library, which
is part of Android support
library, which  means I get open
source, and this is the chosen
path  that you need to provide.
Was it specifically not provided
as the scaling,  but that's
pretty trivial.  We didn't
provide it as part  of the API
because you might want to put in
differentiate children into
the wearable recycleer view.
So to learn more about this API,
you can search  for wearable
recycleer view, the call back
and generally- generally-curved
layout Android Wear and the
developer.   You can just Google
it.  There's plenty of stuff on
slack overflow.  So that's all
for me.  I hope this is  going
to be helpful.  And with that,
I'll hand it over.
[Applause]
>> All right. Thank you. That
was pretty awesome awesome.  All
right.  Let's jump right into
audio  because, first of all,
we're short on time.  So, first
of all, why a new API?  We have
Java API.  We listened  to a
lot of developer feedback and
you told us that  audio
processing is really hard, and
we want to make it  easier to
use.  All of these original APIs
go through  the original audio
framework.  But since making
huge  changes there could
potentially break lots of APIs,
audio has a new server, so we
could introduce a pretty
radical thing that could get us
performance enhancements
enhancements.  So it uses the
concept of streams.  And  in
this case, we can see a stream
flowing from the mic  all the
way back to the app and all the
way back to the  headphones.
And these streams are straight
forward to  create using the
build your design pattern, which
allows  you to create a builder
with your customization to
create multiple screens.  And
this is kind of cool.  You  can
set up
the builder as a rubber stamp
to create audio  streams.  So in
this code, we have an aaudio
stream  builder, and it gives
you the stereo output stream.
And  here's how you would
request certain directions.  You
get input and output stream
from this.  And once you set  up
the stream, you can call the
stream on the builder.   And if
you didn't set things like the
sample rate format format,
you'll need to query them.  And
finally, you get  the frame
reverseed the optimal read,
write size.
And this is kind of how this all
works.  In aaudio aaudio, a
buffer refers to these arrays of
bursts.  And  the data is
written in these bursts, which
actually turn  audio into
something your headphones can
hear.  Yeah,  and in this
diagram, this again rates
generates two bursts of data.
And you can start and pause and
flush your screen.  We  do have
functions that you can
synchronize these.  Again Again,
it's a simple API.  We've got
six minutes.  So  how do we get
data in and out of the streams?
Okay.  So  for apps that don't
need super low Latins latentcy.
It returns  either the number
of frames or the error.  And
this  blocking time can time out
, so we may only get part of
the frame written.  So we need
to be sure to handle that  case.
You need to be running on a
special thread to do  your audio
processing one.  Maybe one that
scheduled.   So you write this
call back function.  And aaudio
will  patch you the stream
parameter.  The audio data buff
and  the number of frames, and
then you can render your audio
into the priority thread.  So
instead of call back  actually
in the building.
All right.  Some people are what
I really want to  do is do
audio processing, that means I
need to take  audio and turn
into something.  So how do I do
that?   Take two or more input
streams and put it in a output?
So what we do in this simple
example, we're just passing
data through the input and the
output, and we read the  input
stream to a nonblocking read.
And that goes right  into the
output buffer.  Notice, it may
take a couple of  calls for
these two screens to synchronize
.  Ta-da.   Finally, let's talk
about dynamic latentcy tuning.
And  this is important because
looking back at our previous
diagram, if we're glitching
because we're getting
preemptive all the time, we
might want to add another  burst
to our renderer.  So this is
the way we do  simplified.  We
can detect overruns or underruns
by  having exrun.  And if it
has changed since the last time
time, you've had a glitch.  So
you can add another burst  to
your buffer size.  Pretty
straight forward.
Once again, here is basic aaudio
using blocking  right.  We've
got extreme stream builder,
pretty straight  forward, we
press start, and then while
we're processing processing, we
just write frames.  Like, kind
of how  audio should work; right
?.  Okay.  And then we close it,
and we're done because, you
know, we're always done.   And
this is a API, so we close
things.
And here's a partial equivalent
of what we would  have to do in
open SLAS.  So, again, the goal
is not  make audio higher
performance, but it also makes
it  easier to write these
programs entirely.  So now
you're  saying, like, but wait.
This is only an Android O.  How
am I going to use this?  The
good news for that is we're
actually working on a C++
wrapper.  And this wrapper is
not only going to target aaudio,
but it's going to work  on
older Android platforms as well.
So you'll be able  to use this
simplified ways with C++ on
both older and  newer versions
of Android.  So pretty cool.
It's going  to have similar
concepts, it's going to use DL
as I am sim ,or  it's going to
have a back-end to talk to SLES.
Cool.   That's it.  We covered
it in four minutes.  It's that
easy.
And it really is.  Like,
honestly, you know, the  audio
developers who have worked with
have used this  already have
come back and said thank you.
And how many  people have
actually tried using their audio
app?  See?   That's how popular
it is.  Anyway, on behalf of
myself  and all of the
presenters who come to the stage
to do  lightning talks, thank
you, all, for coming.  And, you
know, we're going to have
office hours, so today, you  can
come to Android Wear office
hours.  We're going to  have
Android auto office hours
tomorrow and ExoPlayer.   So if
you have any burning questions,
please come back  and talk to us
.  You can also, if you see me
out there,  I can try to answer
questions on Android -- on a
audio  would also be cool.  And
that's it.  Thank you, on
behalf of the panel.
[Applause]
>> All right. We ready? Hello,
GDD, Europe.   Thank you for
coming out and coming in for my
talk.  I'm  Gus Class, and I'm a
developer programs engineer on
the  Google Cloud IoT core
product.  And today I'm going to
be talking about Google Cloud
IoT core.  This talk is a
technical DVD dive.  This means
I'm going to be starting  at the
high level going over the
architectural of the  product
and then covering the product
features and then  finishing low
level by just giving a quick
demo with the  product.  I want
to warn you before I get through
this  is that I'm going to be
covering a whole lot of things.
And as an unfortunate side
effect, the slides came out a
little bit denser than I would
have liked.  So you may  be
tempted to read all the material
on the slides and  all the text
in the diagrams, but please
resist.  It's a  trap.
So I'm going to do my best to
make the slides  available
shortly after the talk.  But you
can take it  all in and take
your time and enjoy the slides
and look  at it with more detail
.  The whole thing's going to be
streamed as well, and it's
recorded, so don't feel like
you need to take pictures.  If
something really kind of  jumps
out at you as important, write
that down and use  it as a take
away.  Just kind of let it go
along as it  goes and understand
that we're covering a lot of
material.
So let's start with some
foundational concepts.   If you
saw a talk before on IoT, the
speaker probably  started with
something to the effect of in X
years,  you're going to have
more devices connected to the
Internet than people.  The
reality is that this actually
actually -- this event horizon
has long since passed us.   And
we're starting to see instead a
trend where there  are going to
be more connected devices than
there are  devices that are not
connected.  So what is IoT
really?   IoT is taking devices
that were not traditionally
connected to the Internet and
then adding Internet  connective
ity to it.  And when you talk
about IoT, you  have to kind of
scope it because there's a lot
of  different -- there's a lot
of different types of IoT.   And
I like to think of it in these
three categories.   You have
home brew and enthusiasts.  So
you have people  that are taking
devices like args between
Arduinos, and then giving  them
Internet capabilities, and then
it gives you  capabilities
that you didn't have before.
So, for  example, I can think of
it as I have a smart flower
watering system.  And before I
was using data logging,  and now
I have Internet connectiveity
to do that data  logging.  And
Google provides a lot of this
stuff to  lobbyists in the AYI
product.  And then the other
area  we have is consumer and
devices.  And so this is things
like you've got a fire alarm or
a smoke detector, and  then you
inner connect it.  You Internet
connect it so  that it can talk
to other is devices and do
intelligent  things.  So
Google offers a lot of these
things.
And the other thing I want to
talk about is  industrial and
commercial domain.  And this is
where you  have a factory where
you have a traditionally
mechanical  assembly line and
then now we've taken that
factory,  we've added a lot of
sensors to it and added a lot of
capabilities that we know
what's going on in that  factory
.  And now we're taking that
data, and then we're  putting it
into the cloud so that we can
do intelligent  things with that
.  And so that last domain that
I was --  that I mentioned,
industrial and commercial is
really  where cloud IoT core
shines.  And for the consumer
device features, you should
really check out Android.   So
why should I care about cloud
IoT core?  I like to  think of
it like this.  If you're like me
, then you did  some home grew
enthusiasts scale IoT.  You were
building  the device yourself.
So you weren't really worried
about things like he will gating
your devices, securing  it
against its backers because you
have a security  through
obscurity,
and you have an audience of
one.  You  know how to manage
that device and so forth.  But
what  if you were building, say,
1,000 devices?  Or 10,000
devices?  Or you're moving up to
a million devices and  all of
these devices need to be set up,
configured,  provisioned,
security, and then you need to
scale out so  that when those
devices are producing tons of
data, that  you're able to
handle it.  So this is where
cloud shines shines.
So we have these systems where
you don't have to  worry about
the capacity that you're
creating.  The  system will
automatically scale up and down
to the needs  that you have.
And so this is where -- this is
why you  should care about
Google Cloud IoT core.  So I'm
going  to give you a background
on what is IoT core?  Just bear
with me, and I'll tell you
about the products that are
important, and then we'll get
into the exciting usage
scenarios.
So on the left, I have IoT core,
and currently,  it's a way of
creating a registry where you
can define  where devices are,
and then connecting your devices
using NQTT to then take your
data and put it into pub/
pub/sub and your data is now in
Google's cloud.  And you  can
use it to trigger API calls or
use data flow to  extract that
data from pub/sub and put it
into bit query  and then do data
analytics on it.  So I'm going
to tell  you a little bit more
about those products so that you
can understand this better.
So what is MQTT?  If you've
heard about it before  before --
if you've worked in IoT before,
you've  probably heard about MQ
TT.  It is a standard that was
designed by IB IBM in the '90s,
and it allows you to  securely
connect devices and transmit
data and receive  messages from
a published subscribe-like
solution.  It's  a binary
protocol, so it's very efficient
on the line,  and it won't use
as much power or require as much
processing power as a lot of
other protocols that you  may be
familiar with.  And so it's
sort of the de facto  standard,
which is why Google adopted it.
So what is  Google Cloud pub/
sub?  Google Cloud
pub/sub is for  publishing and
subscribing.  You create the
topics and  then subscribe to
the topics and then receive
payloads  that were pushed into
those topics.  And it's globally
distributed, and it's reliable
so that you can get at  least
-- when you send messages
through Google Cloud  pub/sub,
you know that they will be
received by the  subscribers at
least
once.  And so when you have
this  large globally-distributed
system, you have to just
certain tradeoffs.  And one of
those tradeoffs is that  you
don't know the order the
messages came in.  And the
other is that the messages only
last inside of that  store for
about seven days.  So what do
you do about  that?  And this is
the last product that I want to
talk  about before we start
talking about architectures.  So
this is data flow.  What data
flow does is it allows you  to
take the stream of messages that
come in through  pub/sub, and
then ensure they're ordered
correctly or  make sure that
they're only once existing
inside of your  persistence data
storeers, and then you can take
them and  put them in other
places, so you can ETL from
pub/sub  very easily using data
flow.
So -- excuse me,.  So what
services are in cloud  IoT core?
And this is what I talked
about very briefly  in that
first diagram showing high level
architecture  for cloud IoT.
There's a device manager, which
I like  to think of as just the
identity solution.  This device
manager knows which devices can
connect to this bridge,  and
then it also will keep track of
-- it will keep  track of the
last time that -- also to
metadata for  those devices,
such as the last time it
connected and  the last time
that configuration was sent to a
device.   And the device
manager also allows you to send
specific  configurations down to
a device, and I'll talk more
about this in a minute.
So the MQTT bridge is something
that works hand in  hand with
the device manager to allow you
to communicate  directly to a
single pub/sub queue.  And so
given these  collections of
services, you can then start to
create  IoT solutions that are
tailored to specific domains of
problem.  And, again, this goes
back to the commercial,
industrial applications first.
And other architectures  and
other platforms can use it as
well.  But when you  think about
this and the context of Android
Things and  other solutions,
it's really well tailored to
industrial industrial.  So the
first thing I want to talk about
is  telemetry analytics.  And
this is when you have  something
like a large weather station
distributed  around the world
that are each simultaneously
parametric  data or position
data that are moving around.
And in  this scenario what you
would typically have is all of
those devices connecting with
massive to cloud IoT core,  and
then cloud IoT core is going to
work one to one with
pub/sub to take that data and
then put it into Google's
cloud.  And then you would
typically use Betty beta flow to
take that data and put it in a
place with analytics.   And
then once that's there, you can
use Google's  analytic product
such as data lab and studio to
analyze  your data and make
predictions and so forth.
So the second thing I want to
talk about, the  second scenario
I want to talk about is device
to device  communication.  So
this is when you have one device
, and  that device could be an
Android Things device or it
could be a memory device like an
ASPA266, and then that  device
is going to try to trigger
another state on  another device
to change.  So we built a demo
around  this where we had all of
these sensors inside the room,
and the sensors were run the so
that the objective when  the
room reached a certain
temperature, we would have
another device that would turn
on a fan.  So in this  scenario,
you would have all of these
devices, and they  could be
Android Things or, you know,
memory devices,  and that would
connect IoT core, which would
pump the  data into pub/sub,
which you could extract using
data  flow, and then you can use
a cloud function to then go
back to the device manager for
cloud IoT core to send a
configuration change to a second
device.  And then that  second
device has the configuration
change something,  like, turn on
your fan, start pumping water
out of the  room, and so forth.
And so I'm going to show you
one  more pattern, then we're
going to start talking about
the platform itself.  And this
last pattern is the same  thing
that we had before, but I want
to put an Android  Things device
in there explicitly.  And
because we want  to have
something like state change
shared or shared  state between
that device in the Android
companion app  or other Web view
.  So if you have some sort of
god view  for, say, a warehouse
for all of these fans, you could
share that state and then
share that state from a
Firebase.  So in this scenario
we'll walk through very  quickly
.  You have this device, and it
connects to cloud  IoT core, and
then cloud IoT core will take
at a data  and put it into
pub/sub, which could then go
through  data flow, which then
could directly trigger state
changes inside of that Firebase
realtime database.  And  then
that --
because the state change's
consistent  between that
database and Android Things,
then the state  could be
triggered to turn on a lightbulb
.  So in this  specific example,
I was thinking of a device, the
first  device or collection of
devices has a server so that
when a room goes dark, the
lights turn on.  So this is  the
foundation for kind of thinking
about the ways that  you can
use this platform to do all
sorts of things that  people
want to do with IoT.
So now it's time to talk a
little bit about the  first
component that is the -- the
first service that is  enabled
through cloud IoT core, the
device manager.  And  so I like
to think about the device
manager as an  identity provider
.  And so what this does -- what
this  means is that it knows
the devices and their
credentials  that can connect to
the service so that they can
then  stream their data to us.
So the device manager uses a
resource model.  And  devices
are defined by using -- so
there's a hierarchy.   So you
have each device associated with
configuration at  the bottom,
and that device also will
contain individual
configuration, and then you can
use the -- and then  those
devices are placed into a
registry, which contains  a list
of devices.  And then you can
programmatically  add and remove
devices.
So
registryies are a way that you
can largely  encapsulate devices
into a store.  And in doing so,
registryies map devices from
the protocol bridge, cloud
pub/sub topics and subscriptions
to pub/sub.  Sorry.
A little thirsty.  So typically
what you're going  to do is
you're going to have a registry
that maps then  to a pub/sub
topic, and then you're going to
probably  extract that data from
that pub/sub topic using data
flow.  And then as such, like,
you're probably going to  want
to have a single place where all
of that data is  going and so
you can then -- we recommend
that you  logically map
everything to a pub/sub topic
and just  have a single registry
.
So before you can add devices
to a registry, you have to be
able to create that  registry.
So we have all of these
solutions for  creating
registers, lifting registers,
deleting  registers, you can do
it all program actually because
we  envision a lot of different
ways that people will use  this.
In certain scenarios, you
would have a device  manufacture
manufacturer who is going to
provision all of the  registry
ies for you.  So you can
delegate these to a  device
manufacturer so that they can do
that and  manufacture.  And
another
scenarios, you're going to
want to be able to do the device
provisioning later.  So  in
this way, we also support that
scenario.
So before you can connect a
device, you have to  create that
device inside of device
registry.  And so we  have what
you would expect.  It's a basic
crud API or  creating, deleting,
reading, enlisting, and so
forth  your devices.  And each
of the devices will have a
unique identifier that's
associated with the device that
has returned from the API when
you create that device.   You
can also get the device and then
get this  information.
But if you look on the JSON
representation, which  is
probably really hard to see on
the screen, but the  JSON
representation has all of this
metadata associated  with the
device.  For example, you know,
the last time  that a
acquisition was sent to the
device and you know  the last
time the device connected and so
forth, and in  in -- and so the
-- this is sort of the magic of
where  the device manager comes
in place.  Because your device
device's connecting and because
we had identity for that  device
, we know the last time the
configuration changes  came to
that device and information such
as the state of  the device.
So you can delegate -- again,
you can delegate the
permissions for device creation
deletion and so forth to  your
manufactured, or you can do it
yourself.
And so this is a good point to
talk about identity identity.
So identity is knowing which
device has  connected, and this
is the magic where all of that
metadata such as the last
heartbeat that came from a
device is made available and
things like wind  configuration
changes came down to a device.
So you can  have -- and so when
you create the identity for a
device device, you're going to
use an an asymmetric encryption
to  give Google your public key
that is associated with a
device credential.  And then
your private key will be on  the
device so that you can use that
private key to  create an
encrypted payload that you send
to Google when  you connect.
And the -- and when you -- and
something  that's kind of
special about our device
configuration is  that we allow
you to create multiple
certificates and  then put them
associated with the device is
that you can  rotate and expire
those certificates.  So you
would do  something like -- I
want to create a device today,
and  then I'm
going to create three
certificates.  The first
expires in a year, the second in
two, and then the third  in
three.  So that way when you're
effectively rotating  your keys
or device credentials.  And I
want to note  never send anyone
your private keys.  It's, like,
just  your password.
So device configuration is the
next thing I want  to talk about
.  Every device has a
configuration  associated with
it that is maintained by the
device  management.  And so what
this means is that you have
this -- something like the state
of the device or if you  want
to have a fan turned on, you
could represent that  in binary
data that I think is what it is
is a JSON  screen.  But we also
-- you could also do something
like  a machine learning model
that you pass down to a device
that is stored inside of binary
data.  And then that  machine
learning model could be updated
on the fly with  the
configuration.  So, again, the
device configuration  is binary
data, but you're welcome to en
code other data  and send it as
that.  And we did this so that
people  could have the flex
ibility to send all sorts of
data  down to the devices.  And
the device manager maintains
ten versions of configurations
that you could roll back  if
something goes wrong when you
send out a  configuration change
.
device  configuration is that
whenever your device
configuration  is changed, so
you send a new version of a
configuration  associated with
the device, that device will
receive a  notification many QTT
-- in MQTT subscription device
change.  So you also get the
subscription every time you
check.  And developers can patch
an old version and then  do
something like roll back to it
if you want to use the  API in
that way.  And the device
acknowledges when it's  it's --
any time that a configuration
comes down to a  device, the
device will notify Google that
it has  acknowledged that
configuration changed.  And this
is  done because we have at
least one delivery of messages
and it could come down down to
devices.
A couple more details about
identity.  When you  connect to
our MQTT end point, you need to
use TLS 1.1  or 1.2, and you
need to use MQTT3.1.1.  I
encountered  issues in the past
using the wrong version.  And go
back  to pub/sub, it has one
delivery but not exactly as a
tradeoff.  So said only QOS one.
So typically the way  that you
use MQTT is you specify the QOS
when you create  the connection
stream.  So just make sure
you're using M MQOS1.  So we
make our connection end point
locally  available at MQTT.
GoogleaPIs.com, and we support
two  ports.  88, 83, which is
the standard QLS port and then
443, which is firewall friendly.
And then the last thing I want
to talk about is  the MQQT
bridge.  And this is a way you
can send  telemetry data from
using the device manager down to
a  specific device.  And then
ways that -- the way that you
send the configuration change
down to the device using  the
device manager and the way that
you can do something  like send
telemetry data, for example, in
one of those  examples earlier
back to Google to store in cloud
and  then warehouse for
analytics for later.
So authentication, again, is
done using an N QTT  client ID,
which is the -- so the ID is
something like  the connection
string.  And that ID is going to
be  unique per device.  And
then the other thing is that you
need a user name, which Google
ignores, so you could put
anything in your user name field
.  And then for the  password,
you have to calculate a jot.
And the jot is  that token that
has an expiration so that this
way you  can prevent, again,
certain types of brute force
attacks attacks.  And because
that jot expires, you need to
have  an expiration time and an
issue at time that is
calculated consistently with
what Google expects.  So  you
can use Google's NTB server,
which is time.Google
time.Google.com in order to get
for free a issued at  time and
calculate the expiration.
So when you publish data, so the
telemetry data or
configuration change twiring
from a device, you're going  to
use the MQTT bridge.  And you
must use this pattern  of
devices/device ID/events and
anything that comes  after
events is going to have -- is
going to be created  with
additional metadata, which we
refer to as a sub subtopic.  So
if you want to create something
like an  alert, you would put
that in devices/device ID/events
/ ID/events/alerts, and then
when the -- when you would  get
that data coming into pub/sub,
it would have that  information
digital alert.
And so when you receive -- when
you want to  receive information
on your devices, you're going
to  need to subscribe to a topic
.  And the topic that you
subscribe to must be devices
slash your device ID slash
config.  Because right now the
only data that can come  down
from Google Cloud IoT core to
your devices is  configuration
change.
So, again, the device
configuration is received on
the device when you connect and
any time that the  configuration
changes and the final detail
that I  haven't mentioned before
is that you do not get the
version number inside of the
device configuration,  you're
welcome to insert it yourself,
or you can also  request
specific versions.
So now that you've gotten a high
level overview of  what the
platform is, I'm going to do a
quick demo.  Of  just kind of
how these -- how the device
manager works,  and then how you
connect using MQTT.
Can everyone see okay?  Okay.
This is good.
So the first thing I'm going to
do is so I'm in a  node sample
directory, and then I'm going to
use the  device manager from
node in order to register a
device  in a registry that I've
already created.
And so the  parameters -- oh,.
Every time.
So I'm going to create a
device using the device manager,
and this -- I'm going  to use
an RSA256 certificate.  So I'm
just going to take  my -- I
already generated in the
previous step a private  key and
a public key using open SSL.
So this RSA cert  that I created
will be sent to Google with a
request to  create a device.
But, yeah, so I'm going to
create a device with  the name
hello, GDD, and then it's going
to be created  in a registry
that I've already created called
MQTT test  Reg, and then I'm
going to use the device
certificate.   And then when the
device gets created, you
receive back  the identifier
that Google calculates for it,
as well as  a configuration for
that.
And so now that I've created the
device, I should  be able to
connect to the MQTT end point
using that jot  for the device
calculating using its public
certificate.   I'm going to copy
this because I keep forgetting
forgetting my  device ID.
Okay.  So now
-- so I'm going to install the
dependencies, which is, like,
an MQTT client.
So, again, I'm going to use --
all right.  Today's  not my
day.  I'm going to hack it and
see what the  parameters were.
So I'm going to have to pass
in my  project ID, the registry
ID, device ID, and then the
path to my public file.
It totally worked earlier.
Every time.  The demo  gods are
not on my side.  So I need to
specify -- so I  at least need
to specify the private key file,
the  project ID, the registry
ID, and the device ID.  Almost
there.  I think just one more.
Doesn't like it when I get a
negative return.
Private key file.
There we go.  Yes.  Maybe.
Okay.   Yes.  Now thank you.
Okay.
[Laughter]
Okay.  So now the data should be
coming into  pub/sub and if you
do a -- if I pull -- this looks
really small.  There we go.
Now if I keep pulling this,
eventually we should start
seeing this -- it is coming  in.
Maybe I jumped the gun there.
Sometimes it takes a little bit
for the messages  to come
through on pub/sub.
Or maybe I put in the wrong
registry, which happens.
Sometimes you forget.
And  then we're almost done.
Let's see.  What did I do
before?  Oh, no, that looks
right.
So it does appear to be
connecting.  It does  appear to
be transmitting those datas --
or it does  appear to be
transmitting the data into the
pub/sub and  imagine if you will
of telemetry messages coming in
.  So  sometimes it can take a
while for the messages to appear
appear, and it seems as though
that's what's happening  now.
But that's pretty much all I
have.  So if we can  return to
the slides, I have just one more
slide to show show.  Oh, did I?
Let's see.
You caught the bug.  MQTT
test dash.  I don't know.
Oh, when I'm reading -- oh,
that's because -- the reason
these are different is this  is
the subscription and then the
registry is entirely
independent of that.  So there's
a topic that you  publish to,
there's a registry associated
with that  topic, and then
there's a subscription that
pulls from  that topic.  So --
yeah, so the subscriptioning is
going  to be different.
Sometimes it does take a minute
for  the messages to get
triggered inside of there, but I
think I'm
doing something else wrong.
But, yeah, that's it.  So we're
currently in a  private beta.
And if we go back to the slides,
we'll be  able to see where we
can get more information about
that that.  So if you go to
cloud.Google.com/IoT core, you
can sign up for the data and
learn more about the  product,
such as details.  Yeah, so it's
like the cusp  of the exciting
time for this product.
Sometimes things  will work,
.
And so thank you for attending
my talk.  I really  appreciate
your time.
[Applause]
And if you want to see more
demos, and you want to  chat
with me more about the product,
I'll be hanging out  at office